wo ich bin vor irgendjemand da kurz was trinken muss ehrlich sagen ich habe die
woche gar nicht mal so viel verfolgt weder was technik sachen angeht noch
irgendwie youtube twitch sonst was weiß ich doch wieder gepieft hat schon oft
gesagt geht mir ziemlich am arsch vorbei zweifelsfall haben sich wieder die üblichen
verdächtigen war die woche irgendwas spannendes so technikmäßig was ich verpasst habe weil ich
muss sagen ich habe also normalerweise lese ich ja immer so ein bisschen quer von hacker news
bis heise und sonstwie aber ich habe mir nichts nichts großartig angeguckt die woche meister
chat kaputt oder moment das muss jetzt mal testen da ist leute da noch keiner was geschrieben
kann
funktioniert ich habe nichts angeguckt ich habe bestimmt irgendwas verpasst ich war die woche zu
sehr beschäftigt mit neben neben arbeiten gehen ab so ein bisschen rumrennen gehen ich musste
mmo kreise kreisen gab nämlich event diese woche jetzt okay heute gab nämlich event diese woche
und wir haben easy gewonnen gestern easy also quasi richtig easy
wollten ja wir haben so hoch gewonnen oder so gehe gewonnen dass die anderen ausgelockt
sind und liebe harte gespielt haben
so schön ist es sehr schade das heise keine oder golem oder wer auch
immer für supervisor news gab's früher meine ganz gute wochen zusammen fassung gibt es auch
schon eine weile nicht mehr ich suche schon ich hab's ja auch schon para im stream gesagt ich suche
nach einer guten IT-News-Zusammenfassung für die Woche.
Ich habe noch keine wirklich gute gefunden, die mir gefällt.
Entweder beschäftigt es sich mit zig Dingen, die mich nicht interessieren,
oder keine Ahnung, es ist...
Weiß nicht, hat da jemand vielleicht irgendwelche guten Empfehlungen oder so?
Ich habe bis jetzt noch nichts gefunden.
Warum habe ich ja eigentlich immer noch das Windows ME ISO auf dem Desktop liegen?
Nein, ich will nicht updaten, weil das neueste Vmware-Workstation ziemlich im Arsch.
Wir machen mal Package-Updates, bis der Stream richtig angelaufen ist.
Irgendwie hat Twitch gerade noch so ein paar kleine Startschwierigkeiten.
Moin Martin.
Machen wir mal Package-Updates, weil 8 Linux, by the way, da gibt es auf jeden Fall neue Packages.
Das ist auch so ein Ding, was ich nicht verstehe, ist,
viele Leute haben ja unter Linux so einen grafischen Login-Manager,
oder Start, weiß gar nicht, wie das Ding genau heißt,
und da frage ich mich, warum einen grafischen Login-Manager,
wenn man doch einfach auch Kommandozeilen-Login machen kann und an X starten.
The Hacker Man Way.
Warum starte ich Firefox? Ich will eigentlich nur Package-Updates machen.
Das updatet eh Firefox und Kernel und alles nach einer Woche.
Muss ich eh rebooten gleich.
Und was haben wir hier?
Bind, Alter, warum habe ich überhaupt...
Wahrscheinlich für NS-Lookup und so Zeug.
Bin nicht sicher, ob das überhaupt ein Bind-Tool ist.
Headers, Wireshark.
Ah, okay, ne.
Doch, doch, Linux-Kernel-Update.
Yes.
Lass ich auch noch updaten.
Dann sind Package-Updates durch.
Ich habe übrigens ein sehr nices Projekt gefunden,
auf Shithub,
was wir uns heute Mittag im Stream mal angucken werden.
Ich bin ja immer so auf der Suche
nach neuen Monitoring-Tools,
sowohl für das Business-Enterprise-Umfeld als auch für daheim.
Was es da so gibt.
Wir haben ja auch die meisten schon mal uns ein bisschen angeguckt.
Ja, ich hänge hier immer noch auf einer ollen Zabbix-Installation daheim,
weil ich das halt irgendwann mal eingerichtet habe und es funktioniert halt.
Aber ich mag Zabbix auch nicht.
Ich mag eigentlich so gut wie keine Monitoring-Tool.
Das Ding.
Ich habe ein weiches Herz für Nagios,
aber nicht, dass ich es verwenden wollen würde,
sondern einfach nur, weil es das erste dieser Art ist, was ich benutzt habe
und mich als Azubi damals...
darum gekümmert habe.
Und ich mag die Customizability-Möglichkeiten,
die man hat, beispielsweise mit Prometheus.
Aber so der Weisheit als letzter Schluss ist das alles irgendwie nicht.
Deswegen.
Ich habe was Neues entdeckt.
So, nachher mal ausprobieren, gucken, ob das taugt.
Zwar nennt sich das, ich zeige es euch mal, OpenObserve.
Da sind es anscheinend hauptsächlich für Anwendungsmonitoring gedacht,
aber, nachdem das auch Prometheus mit trinken
und OpenTermilitaryCollectioner,
die, äh, Kollektor-Sachen, frisst,
kann man das auch für so gut wie alles andere verwenden.
Jetzt wollte ich mal angucken, ob das taugt.
Da immer, immer gut informt zu sein.
Moin, Rektmann.
So, Package-Updates sind durch.
Hatte ich jetzt jetzt eigentlich auch die User-Repost geupdatet, ja.
Gucken wir mal, ob bei JetBrains irgendwas Neues da ist.
Machen wir mal komplett Package-Updates überall.
Äh...
Aqua.
Hat das mal irgendjemand verwendet?
JetBrains hat ja mittlerweile so 1000 Sachen.
Und da sind ja auch einige dabei, wo ich mich so frage,
wer und wann verwendet das eigentlich, ja?
Also das da zum Beispiel, RightSight, keine Ahnung,
noch nie installiert, noch nie geöffnet, noch nie angeguckt.
Aber wir wissen ja, Documentation, ne?
Wer braucht schon Documentation, wenn die Sachen funktionieren, ne?
Wenn's geht einfach, da muss man auch nichts dokumentieren,
weil wenn's immer geht, muss auch keiner reparieren und dann...
braucht man auch keine Docs.
So, also keine Ahnung, was das hier eigentlich sein soll, genau.
Aqua hab ich auch noch nie gesehen.
IDI for Test Automation.
Warum er eine IDE braucht für Tests?
Whatever, keine Ahnung, JetBrains.
Hat bestimmt seinen Sinn.
Wirklich, ja, checken, warum es da so viele verschiedene gibt, keine Ahnung.
Ja, Fleet ist auch so ein Ding, das haben sie ja mal gestartet.
Vor zig, zig Jahren, das ist ja auch schon bestimmt 3, 4 Jahre alt.
Um mit Visual Studio Code zu konkurrieren.
Hat's bis jetzt nicht geschafft.
Und ich sehe auch niemand, der hauptsächlich Fleet verwendet.
Dataspel hab ich auch noch nie verwendet.
Wie gesagt, nur weil ich das nicht verwendet habe, weiß der nicht, dass es schlecht ist oder so, ne?
Ich frag mich halt nur, wer und wann und wie verwendet man das?
Und weshalb?
WebStorm.
Ja, WebStorm ist tatsächlich nicht schlecht.
WebStorm verwende ich aber nicht.
Ich verwende für Frontend Sachen lieber Visual Studio Code.
C-Line verwende ich ab und zu.
PHPStorm, ja, wenn's sein muss.
Datacrypt.
Muss tatsächlich ganz nice sein, glaub ich.
Für alle, die viel mit Datenbank-Krams hantieren.
Ja, .NET Profile, das haben wir schon mal verwendet.
RubyMine hab ich früher auf das verwendet.
Space Desktop.
Das ist, glaub ich, die Codespace Alternative.
Ne, wie heißt das?
Workspace Alternative von JetBrains.
Auch noch nicht verwendet.
Keine Ahnung.
Auch so ein Ding.
Ja, immer auch das verwendet.
Gut, Android Studio, klar.
Pyjama, Gateway, auch keine Ahnung.
Also die Hälfte davon ist so ein Ding, wo ich verwendet habe.
Für wen, für was und warum?
So, Reboot.
Jet, was ist denn mit euch los heute Morgen?
Keiner sagt was.
Alle noch Badge...
Ja, ist ja auch Aufwachen-Stream.
Da ist es erlaubt.
Gateway ist eigentlich nice.
Ich hab jetzt von der kurzen Übersicht nicht gecheckt, was es eigentlich sein soll.
Was hältst du von Grafana?
Grafana ist das beste Visualisierungstool.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ich hab ein paar andere ausprobiert.
Ich hab Tele...
Ja, wie heißt das Ding?
Nicht Telegraph.
Telegraph...
Dieses...
Chronograph oder so.
Das InfluxDB.
Das InfluxDB-Ding hab ich ausprobiert.
So, und dann hab ich noch das Elasticsearch-Ding ausprobiert.
Ist das Kibana?
Bin mir aus dem Kopf nicht ganz sicher.
Ist Kibana, Kibana das Grafana-Äquivalent von Elasticsearch, geht uns?
Das hab ich auch ausprobiert.
Und ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen, Grafana...
Leider geht mir Grafana ein bisschen zu sehr in letzter Zeit in die Richtung.
Ja, wir haben coole Connector und alles, aber das ist nur noch für Enterprise Edition.
Aber Grafana ist für mich die beste Mischung aus...
Man checkt es relativ easy, wie es funktioniert.
Die ganzen Query-Languages für die unterschiedlichen Sachen, ja.
Und dass man auch was Gescheites rauskriegt.
Da ist ja nichts wirklich Grafana dran schuld.
Das ist, je nachdem was man fährt, ein bisschen komplizierter.
Aber so, insgesamt finde ich ist Grafana das Beste aus Übersichtlichkeit.
Es ist easy zu installieren.
Letztendlich ist Grafana, glaube ich, einfach nur ein einzelnes Go-Binary.
Man kann es starten, weil die meisten es wahrscheinlich in irgendeinem Docker starten werden.
Im Container starten werden.
Also ich finde Grafana ist das beste Visualisierungstool, was es gibt.
Deswegen bin ich mal gespannt.
Gucken wir uns heute Mittag mal OpenObserve an.
Da ist alles mit dabei.
Das ist...
Metriken.
Logs.
Traces.
Alles mögliche mit dabei.
Und das wohl in einer UI.
Und relativ easy zu starten.
Mal gespannt, ob das taugt.
Ja.
Also ich finde Grafana ist das beste Visualisierungstool.
Grafana alleine bringt natürlich auch nichts.
Grafana alleine...
Da fehlt ihr halt...
Warum kann ich meine Session nicht restoren?
Grafana alleine für Monitoring ist halt auch nichts.
Grafana ist nur der Visualisierungspart.
Also sowohl für Alerts.
Als auch für das Datencollecten an sich braucht man was.
Ja ich weiß Grafana hat mittlerweile ihr...
Wie nennt sich das?
Unified Alerting oder so.
Das habe ich aber noch nie ausprobiert.
Weiß ich nicht wie gut oder schlecht das ist.
Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das ein bisschen hakelig ist.
Wenn du mehr machen willst als Wert ist über oder Wert ist unter von irgendwas.
Aber weil keine Ahnung habe ich noch nie großartig ausprobiert.
Aber ich bin auch der Meinung Alert schicken ist gar nicht mal so sehr die Aufgabe von Grafana.
Ja ich habe ganz viele Ideen für neues YouTube Video.
Oh du Mist ich habe eine riesenlange Liste und da kommt auch immer was dabei.
Ich habe sogar auf dem Handy noch eine extra Liste.
Aber ich habe gerade so irgendwie gar keine Motivation YouTube zu machen.
Ich weiß das...
Sackt jetzt für einige so ein bisschen.
Für mich ja auch.
Übrigens ich wurde richtig gebetet.
Ich habe hier eine Abrechnung liegen von meinem Doktor.
Und zwar hat der...
Also ich lese euch das mal vor.
Also Blut abnehmen kostet 4,19€.
Weil Faktor 1,8.
Okay.
So dann gibt es die Sachen die getestet wurden.
Und dann...
Und dann kommt es.
Dann hat er noch abgerechnet.
Eingangsberatung 10,72€.
Mir ist nicht bewusst das in irgendeiner Art und Weise dort irgendeine Beratung stattgefunden hätte.
Ich weiß nicht auf welche Art er mich angeblich irgendwie beraten hat.
Aber kann man natürlich super abrechnen ja.
Ich meine 10,72€ ist jetzt auch nicht so das Ding.
Aber schon ein bisschen cheap baited.
Oh.
Moin.
Zabbix.
Ja ich habe daheim auch einen Zabbix laufen.
Aber ich bin.
Wie gesagt.
Ich habe es schon oft gesagt.
Ich bin mit keinem Monitoring Tool so richtig glücklich.
Gerade für den Heimbereich nicht.
Heimbereich will ich irgendwas Super Easy mäßiges haben.
Eine GUI.
Und da drin ein bisschen rumklicken.
Alles was ich brauche.
Ja.
Zabbix ist nur Enterprise 0.
Du kannst doch Zabbix daheim verwenden.
Das Problem an Zabbix ist.
Das Zabbix abartig zu konfigurieren ist über das Wörter Interface.
Aber immerhin.
über das Webinterface, aber immerhin, es ist ein Webinterface und man kann alles, oder zumindest 99%, außer irgendwelche Custom-Check-Definitionen oder sowas, kann man im Webinterface machen.
Das ist ein echter Vorteil von Zabbix. Zabbix, muss man aber sagen, ist insgesamt so als All-in-One-Monitoring-Solution ein bisschen aus der Zeit gefallen durch die Architektur.
Also, glaube ich, ist es zumindest meine Auffassung des Ganzen, weil Zabbix selbst kommt aus einer Zeit, also ich zeige das mal hier, Zabbix, das da meine ich, Zabbix kommt aus einer Zeit, da hat man noch, das ist übrigens, oh Moment, das ist Grafana, wollte ich gerade sagen, ja, so sieht das im Endeffekt aus, das Dashboard.
Also, Zabbix kommt aus einer Zeit.
Da hat man noch ganz klassisch, das größte Teil des Monitorings damals als Zabbix entstanden ist, war klassisches, wir gucken von außen drauf Monitoring, ja, wir gucken, ob ein Service up oder down ist, indem wir checken, ob ein Port auf ist, ob eine SSH-Verbindung geht, ob das Ganze pingt, ob das eine Ordner-Response liefert, plus, um Infos von einzelnen Systemen zu bekommen, hat man eine Zabbix-Agent installieren müssen und das war es im Endeffekt.
So, aus der Zeit kommt Zabbix.
Also, die Dashboards, die man in Zabbix machen kann, können auch null, aber wirklich null, auch wenn man es vielleicht hier auf den ersten Blick nicht sieht, ja, weil es hier noch ganz hübsch aussieht, aber die können absolut null mithalten mit Grafana.
Die sind super hakelig zum Reinscrollen, Rausscrollen überhaupt und die Möglichkeiten an verschiedenen Graphen und wie man das aufbereitet, ist wirklich Lichtjahre, ja, hinter Grafana.
Jetzt kommen wieder die Leute und sagen, ja.
Actually, Max, Lichtjahre sind Entfernung und keine Zeit.
Jaja, ist okay.
Ich wollte das nur verdeutlichen, wie weit das hinter Grafana ist.
Leute, die müssen aber sowas einhaken.
Nein, nein, nein, ich weiß es aber besser.
Moin, Fips.
Ja, und in der heutigen Zeit ist es allerdings so, dass man nicht nur, also wenn es um Systemüberwachung geht oder generell ums Überwachen geht,
dass man nicht nur...
So, ich nenne das mal Blackbox-Monitoring machen will, so von außen gucken, ist Service ab, ist Port offen, ist Ping ja, ja, nein, Domain löst auf und sowas.
Oder eben per Agent mit Sachen collecten will.
Heute hast du noch deutlich mehr.
Heute willst du Anwendungsmetriken collecten, generell relativ viele Metriken collecten und wir reden hier nicht von, ja, einmal in der Minute einen Ping ausführen und gucken, ob es funktioniert,
sondern wir reden hier teilweise von tausenden Metriken pro Sekunde.
Und das kann entweder durch Prometheus-Collectors passieren oder durch irgendwelche Exporter in der Anwendung, OpenTelemetry will man auch noch collecten und es gibt heute auch noch die ganze, ja, Cloud- und Containerwelt, die ihre unterschiedlichen Endpunkte haben für Monitoring, wie man beispielsweise im Kubernetes-Cluster die Workloads überwacht.
Du willst ja nicht nur überwachen, so was macht dein Workload selbst, ja, du willst ja auch noch überwachen, so was macht denn der Cluster an sich.
Hat der noch genug freie IPs, um neue Workloads und neue Pods zu schedulen und sowas, willst du dir alles angucken, das heißt, du musst auch irgendwie da rein.
War lange nachdem Zabbix erfunden wurde, dann willst du heute mittlerweile eigentlich auch im gleichen Monitoring-Tools zumindest Zugriff auf Log-Auswertung haben.
Das war Zabbix auch nicht so ohne weiteres.
Das heißt, Zabbix ist ein bisschen, finde ich, so ein bisschen aus der Zeit gefallen.
Ja.
Aber ich habe daheim immer noch einen Zabbix am Start, weil ich den mal eingerichtet habe und der läuft.
Das ist auch noch ein bisschen ältere Version, irgendwie 6.8 oder sowas.
Was ist das? React Everywhere.
Das ist der Office-Installer.
Ne, ist das das Startmenü?
Ist das das Startmenü?
Was bin ich da überhaupt sehend?
Also, ja, das ist anscheinend das Startmenü.
Also, zumindest dieser Teil hier.
Also, ich wusste, dass bei Microsoft relativ viel React ist.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es wusstet, aber...
Office im Browser ist auch React.
Ist auch eine React-Anwendung.
Es heißt ja auch nicht mehr Office.
Was eines der bescheuertsten Renames ever ist.
Warum eigentlich wurde Microsoft, äh, wurde eigentlich Office 365...
Ich fand übrigens Office 365 schon immer bescheuert, ja, aber...
Okay, warum wurde eigentlich, wie kommt man, kam man auf die glorreiche Idee,
Office 365 in Microsoft 365 umzubelennen?
Jeder nennt das Ding Office.
Warum Microsoft 365?
Das ist so hängen geblieben, einfach nur.
Ja, und wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das wusstet.
Die Browser-Version von Office 365, die ist auch React.
Die ist auch in React programmiert.
Ja.
Wir haben auch tatsächlich auf der Arbeit noch einen Check-MK.
Aber der macht halt zum größten Teil so die klassischen Monitoring-Sachen.
So wie halt, läuft Zertifikat ab?
Ist das Service da?
Antwortet der Agent und sowas?
So großartiges Metriken-Collecten oder gar Traces von Anwendungen und sowas.
Und auch die Log-Auswertung von Check-MK ist sehr, ja, hakelig.
Und ein großes Problem, was Check-MK hat, was Zabbix auch ein bisschen hat,
aber Zabbix nicht so sehr.
Ein großes Problem von Check-MK, was ich damit habe, ist,
dass die, glaube ich, das ist keine Ahnung wie alt Check-MK ist,
ich sag jetzt einfach mal 50.
15 Jahre alt oder so.
Und dass die von diesen 15 Jahren, 14,5 Jahre keinen UI-Designer hatten.
Das Check-MK-UI ist einfach, wir klatschen die Sachen überall hin,
wo wir gerade noch einen Platz finden.
Guckt euch dieses, ja, das ist, das ist die schöne Dashboard-View.
Das wollen wir ja einfach gar nicht, ja.
Konflikt.
Hier, ja.
Ja.
Ja, da wird's schon, da wird's schon eklig, ja, Mann.
Ja, hier.
Diese, also das UI von Check-MK ist wirklich, guckt euch das hier an, Alter.
Wer hat, wer, wer macht sowas?
Ja, wer designt solche Oberflächen?
Und das sind jetzt nur kleine Ausschnitte, dass es übersichtlich ist, aus denen ihr in Docks.
Normalerweise, wenn du sowas aufmachst, ist dieser Abschnitt Teil von einer, ja, keine Ahnung, ähm,
10-seitigen Config, die du durchscrollen musst im Browser, ja.
Guckt euch, guckt euch diesen Kram an.
Also, die, die Typen bei Check-MK, die hatten kein UI-Designer.
Das ist übrigens nix, was ich mir ausgedacht hab, dass die keinen UI-Designer haben.
Das haben die, das haben die inoffiziell, inoffiziell selbst bestätigt, weil die seit einem halben Jahr oder so in ihrem...
...Wort, oder wie man das nennt, haben die einen UI-Designer, der dort regelmäßig postet.
Und der postet halt irgendwie erst seit einem halben Jahr.
Die hatten, die hatten die letzten Jahre einfach keinen.
Ja, ja, gut, du kannst ja, wenn du weißt wie, ja.
Aber es ist trotzdem wichtig, dass die Dinger irgendwie bedienbar sind.
Hab ich mich noch nicht mit beschäftigt.
Ja.
Also, das ist so eins meiner Probleme, die ich mit Check-MK hab, dass das Interface und die Config halt so für'n Arsch ist.
Plus, dass es halt teilweise mega unintuitiv ist, wenn ich sowas hier lese.
Im Job-Down-Menü haben wir zusätzlich noch die Möglichkeit, Refresh All Services tabula rasa auszuwählen.
Obviously, dass man das machen kann, ja, alles klar.
Ja, das hast du, das musst du manchmal machen, wenn das irgendwelche neuen Services nicht discovert werden.
Also, das Interface von Check-MK ist wirklich grausam.
Und nicht nur das Config-Interface ist grausam.
Ja, ich hab das sogar schon aufgemacht.
Nicht nur das Config-Interface ist grausam von Check-MK.
Sondern auch das reine, wir gucken uns jetzt die Sachen an, Monitoring-Interface ist grausam.
Wenn ich mich jetzt dazwischen entscheiden müsste, was ich Interface-technisch besser finde als Check-MK, also Zabbix oder Check-MK.
Dann würde ich eindeutig sagen Zabbix.
Aber es ist auch nicht einfacher.
Es ist zumindest etwas logischer, wenn man sich dran gewöhnt hat.
Und man kann sich etwas einfacher dran gewöhnen.
Crap ist das Zabbix-Interface auch.
Deswegen mag ich beides nicht so wirklich.
Ja, deswegen gucken wir uns heute Mittag mal Open Observe an.
Das habe ich letztens auf Hacker-News gefunden.
Und das kann angeblich, natürlich das allerwichtigste, Leute.
Ne?
Blazingly fast, weil written in Rust.
Das Kriterium schlechthin, warum wir nur noch diese Software verwenden.
So, und die sagen, die können alles in einem.
Die können, ja das kann man sich selbst installieren.
Die wollen ja einfach nur ihren Cloud-Shit verkaufen.
Die machen Logs, Metriken, Dashboards, Traces, alles mögliche in einem Tool.
Plus, dass sie ganz normal OpenTelemetry und Prometheus-Sachen ingesten können.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Ob das taugt.
Weil so Versprechungen von, ja wir sind die beste Monitoring-Lösung überhaupt.
Gibt es ja einige.
Gehalten haben es wenige.
Was dafür spricht, dass es gar nicht schlecht ist, sind die GitHub-Sternchen.
Und was ich nice finde, dass es ein einziges, ein einzelnes Binary ist zum Ausführen.
Das probieren wir heute Mittag mal aus.
Und wir probieren nicht den Service von denen aus.
Sondern wir installieren uns das selbst.
Was in der Tat recht easy ist.
Weil man das einfach im Docker-Container starten kann.
Oder alternativ kann man sich, glaube ich, einfach auch das, es ist übrigens kein Go-Binary,
das Rust-Binary runterladen und gut ist.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob das taugt.
Gerade Integration von OpenTelemetry mit Logs und Prometheus ist nice.
Weil sobald du Prometheus integrieren kannst, schon von Bend gehört.
Ja, da habe ich das Video gerade von Fireship aufgemacht.
Sobald du Prometheus integrieren kannst, kannst du gut wie alles.
Also da bin ich mal gespannt drauf.
Okay.
Dann lasst uns doch gerade mal die aktuellen Shit-Hub-Trends uns angucken.
Hast du mal Bock auf einen 3D-Druck, champ, in.net, um Chinesen-Cloud loszuwerden?
Was?
Den, okay.
Ich verstehe die Wörter, aber ich verstehe nicht, was du meinst.
Also ich verstehe, du meinst, ob ich irgendwas programmieren kann, um Chinesen-Cloud loszuwerden.
Das verstehe ich nicht.
Wieso?
Wie jetzt?
Was jetzt?
Was soll der...
Tobo Nautilus, das musst du mir ein bisschen genauer erklären.
Ich meine, ich kann schlecht was programmieren, was hier in China was ausdruckt, oder?
Ach, jetzt weiß ich, was du meinst.
Hast du einen 3D-Drucker, der Chinesen-Cloud-Sachen braucht, dass er funktioniert, oder was?
Dann nimm doch Octoprint, gibt es doch schon seit Jahren.
Das ist das Beste, was es gibt.
Ansonsten musst du mir das etwas genauer erklären.
Also hier, ich zeige euch das mal.
Octoprint oder Octopie, da hat man es gleich von Raspberry Pi.
Octoprint.
Raspberry Pi.
Raspberry Pi drauf.
Per USB an seinen 3D-Drucker angestöpselt.
Und man kann seinen 3D-Drucker über das Webinterface füttern, mit Druck aufdrehen, gucken, wie weit es ist und alles.
Und es gibt tausende Plugins für alles Mögliche, was man so haben können möchte.
Sogar für Kameras, dass man zugucken kann, wie gedruckt wird und so.
Wobei ich die Kamera wieder entfernt habe.
Also was ich noch habe.
Am 3D-Drucker vorne so eine Beleuchtung dran.
Dass es leuchtet, wenn er druckt.
Was sehr nice ist, wenn man eine Kamera in dem Raum hat.
Und gucken will, was das Gedrucke gerade so macht.
Ja.
Aber wenn man irgendwas braucht zum 3D-Drucker steuern, ist Octoprint eigentlich das Beste.
Und dadurch, dass es das als...
Ja, so kannst du dir das dann zusammenbauen, genau.
Ja.
Und dadurch, dass es das als fertiges Raspberry Pi Image gibt, mit Octoprint drinnen.
Gibt es eigentlich kaum was einfacheres, was man verwenden kann.
Die Anzeige hier, wie viel Time left ist, ist nicht so hundertprozentig akkurat.
Aber die ist...
Für grobe Richtwert ist die eigentlich ganz gut.
Zumal es Plugins gibt, um die genauer zu machen.
Also plus minus paar Minuten genau ist die.
Was bei 3D-Druckjobs ja reicht.
Ja, 3D-Druckjobs sind ja selten unter einer Stunde.
So, wenn es ein bisschen größeres ist.
Ja.
Dann ist Octoprint das Beste.
Ich habe auch schon ewig nicht mehr updatet.
Ja, ich habe noch irgendeine uralte Version drauf.
Aber die geht halt einfach.
Und ich druck mit meinem 3D-Drucker auch gar nicht so viel.
Ich druck ab und zu mal entweder irgendwelche Gehäuse für irgendwelches Bastelkram.
Oder aber irgendwie Kleinkram.
Ja, ich habe zum Beispiel letztens mal...
Weil letztens ist auch schon wieder ein Jahr her oder so.
Mal ein Sieb gedruckt für eine Regenrinne.
Die keine Standardregen...
Die keine Standardregenrinnengröße hat.
Für solche Sachen sind 3D-Drucker perfekt.
Man glaubt gar nicht mal, dieses 3D-Drucker-Zeug, das...
Was ist so das 0815-Filament, was dabei ist?
Ich kann mir das immer nicht merken.
Das ist sehr beständig, ja.
Also das ist sehr stabil.
Was es glaube ich nicht so mag...
Also mal gucken, wie lange das in der Regenrinne hält.
Was es glaube ich nicht so mag, ist Sonnenlichteinstrahlung.
Den ganzen Tag.
Wenn du heute ein Bambulab kaufst, dann ist es Plug & Play aber auch nur, weil App wie der Chinesen...
OktoPrint ist Python, das ist richtig.
Aber das ist doch für Anwender egal so, was das ist.
Wenn schon, müsste das rewritten in Rust sein.
Moment, Moment.
Es gibt doch bestimmt OktoPrint-Alternative in Rust, oder?
Das kann ich mir...
Das...
Die Leute rewriten alles wie verrückt in Rust.
Okay, es gibt anscheinend keine OktoPrint-Alternative in Rust.
Es macht auch keinen Sinn, ehrlich gesagt.
OktoPrint ist ja wirklich nicht mehr...
OktoPrint ist ja wirklich nicht performance-kritisch, irgendwie.
Ja...
Ne, aber...
Das ist...
Erstens, ein Thema, was mich gerade nicht sonderlich interessiert.
Weshalb ich schon mal dann das nicht mache.
Das zweite ist, es ist ein enorm riesen Projekt, irgendwas in der Richtung zu bauen.
Ich habe überhaupt keine Ahnung davon.
Und es gibt eine gute Alternative, also dann...
Dann sollte ich lieber den Fiat Champ mal weiterbauen.
Der sicherlich immer noch keine Issues hat, oder?
Ne, immer noch, obviously, immer noch nicht.
So, also, was trennt ihr denn auf Shithub die Woche?
Zeigt mal her.
Echt?
Okay.
Wusste... Wusste ich gar nicht...
Dass es sowas gibt.
Ich dachte, die ganzen 3D-Drucker haben alle eine USB-Schnittstelle, wo du dann dein Raspberry Pi anschließen kannst.
Zumindest alle, die ich bisher gesehen habe.
Und den...
Ich habe mich da jetzt aber auch die letzten Jahre, seitdem ich meinen habe, nicht mehr mit beschäftigt.
So, ein typisches Thema wie neue PC kaufen.
Ich beschäftige mich dann damit, wenn es soweit ist.
Also, was trennt ihr diese Woche?
Clans, Dashboards...
Ja, das braucht TechnoTim!
dass man...
Ja, auch irgendwas in den drei Kubernetes-Clustern daheim
und einen in der Eintrittsch chamst du Home,
...dass man da was hosten kann.
So.
Chat-GPT desktop-App.
It users something in RUST.
Ganz wichtig!
TimeSFM
TimeSeriesFoundation
Ah, AI
Ich weiß nicht, was das sein soll
More Relighting
Ah, irgendwelches AI-Zeug
Okay
AI-Zeug
AI-Generated
Content wird AI-Generated
geleitet
Okay, alles klar
Belichtet
AI
China-Chinesen-Kram
Warp-Clash-API
What?
Ich habe absolut keine Ahnung, was das sein soll
Cloudflare Warp Plus
This project
aims to use Cloudflare Warp Plus
through subscription automation
Was ist
Cloudflare Warp
Ist das ein VPN?
Ist das ein
Was?
Das ist der DNS von
von
Okay, es ist so eine Art VPN
Ach, deswegen
Deswegen stehen da die Chinesen auch so drauf
Okay
Die Uhr ist nice, ne?
Da weiß man jetzt gar nicht mehr so genau, was Domain, Top-Level-Domain und Sub-Domain ist
Okay, doch, man weiß es
One ist die Top-Level-Domain
One ist die eigentliche Domain
Und dann gibt es eine Sub-Domain mit einer weiteren Sub-Domain
Also, aber eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Idee
Meinst du nicht, dass du eventuell
irgendwann von dem AI-Zeug abgehängt wirst
wenn du dich damit so blockierend beschäftigst?
Beschäftige ich mich damit blockierend?
Ich gucke mir die ganzen Github-Projekte dazu nicht an
Weil es meistens für mich überhaupt nicht klar ist
wofür die Dinger da sind
und ich mich weder für Image-Generating
noch sonst was interessiere
Ich beschäftige mich da selektiv damit
wenn ich es für sinnvoll halte
Kennst du
Ja, das ist die Facebook-Geschichte
Facebook-Image-Gedöns
Lama, nicht das Facebook-Image-Gedöns?
Außerdem, ich glaube, jeder wird von der AI-Entwicklung
abgehängt, der sich nicht jeden Tag
vier Stunden damit beschäftigt, was Neues gibt
Ja, und ich meine, was juckt einen
irgendein weiteres Chat-GPT-Desktop-Web-Interface?
Who cares?
Auch AI-Image-Generating
Ja, guckt, das ist gefühlt wieder 80%
irgendwelches Image-Generating-AI
diese Woche gewesen
No offense, doch
Ich bin voll offended, ich banne dich jetzt
Direkt, kick, für immer
Ich bin immer wieder
Ich entdecke immer wieder neue GitHub-Sachen
Mir ist erst letztens aufgefallen
dass jetzt hier auch neuerdings Developers trenden können
Developers, Developers, Developers
Ah, siehste
Aber ist Lama nicht
Lama ist doch die Facebook-AI
Warum heißt das dann OL-Lama?
Mein Gott, können die ihre Produkte nicht mal gescheit benennen?
Okay, das sind wohl die trendenden Developer diese Woche
Alles zu hier
Und eine Runde AskIquarium
Exakt
Ja, Chat, jetzt wo ein bisschen mehr Leute da sind
Kennt ihr irgendeine gute Seite
McFly, danke schön für den Sub
die wöchentliche
IT-News-Übersichten
bietet, die was taugt, ja
Ich hab bisher noch keine gefunden
die mir gefällt
Heise macht sowas nicht mehr, die hatten früher mal eine ganz brauchbare
Es gibt keine Hacker-News, gescheite Hacker-News-Wochen-Zusammenfassung mehr
Ich, ich, ich sag
Hacker-News ist so ein Ding
Das musst du jeden Tag lesen
Ich meine Wochen-Zusammenfassung
Es gab früher eine ganz gute Hacker-News-Zusammenfassung
Die gibt es aber schon eine Weile nicht mehr
Hacker-News gucke ich auch öfters rein
Aber ich meine Wochen-Zusammenfassung
Irgendwas, wo du so
So, sagen wir mal
Freitag, Samstag oder Samstag mal gucken kannst du
Ey, was ist in die Woche wirklich wichtiges
IT-mäßig passiert
Hab ich vielleicht irgendwas verpasst
An die wichtigsten Sachen kriegt man ja immer mit
Sei es hier im Stream
Über Twitter
Was ja schon seit Ewigkeiten nicht mehr Twitter heißt
Aber sagt, gibt es, Chat
Gibt es von euch irgendjemand, der X sagt
Anstelle von Twitter
Also ich sag immer Twitter
Und ich werde auch weiterhin Twitter sagen
Selbst, selbst wenn die Domain
Mittlerweile ja auch komplett unbenannt ist
Also ob sie direkt auf
Einer sagt X
X ist auch so eine dumme Domain, Alter
X, könnte man sagen, ja
Ja, das, das sagen die immer in irgendwelchen News-Sendungen
X, ehemalig, wird ehemals Twitter
So
Ich glaube sogar, dass PayPal ursprünglich mal X hieß, gell
Und
Dass dann PayPal wurde
Ich hab mir irgendwann mal die History davon angeschaut
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau
Zumindest
Irgendwie, irgendwie finde ich das geil
Dass die Dinger X heißen
Ampel, danke
Pogsubscription
Das erste Logo hat ein X drauf, okay
Wie gesagt, ich sag auch, ich sag auch immer Twitter
Und ich, ich werde auch weiterhin Twitter
Weil, das Ding ist halt
Bei Twitter hast du nicht gesagt
Ich poste jetzt was auf Twitter
Da haben die Leute gesagt, ich poste jetzt was auf Twitter
Ein Tweet oder getweetet oder so
Das fand ich eigentlich immer ein ganz nettes Wort
Das von allen immer
Also jedem klar war, man postet was auf Twitter
AI-Goals
Du wirst nicht abgehängt von AI-Entwicklung
Bei dem Namen
Wie gerade der Chat befürchtet hat
Ja
Aber wie nennt man das denn auf X
Ja, ge-X, ge-X
Ich hab was ge-X
Ge-X heißt bei uns auf Deutsch
Eher wie sowas, ich hab's auf einen Schlag ausgesprochen
Ausgedrungen
Ich hab was ge-X
Das ist aber ziemlich Boomer
Gesichtsbuch anstatt Facebook
Zu sagen
Sagst du auch
Win doof von Mini weich
Das ist auch so ein typisches Boomer Ding
Mit dem Under Serial
Ausgerechnet mit dem Under Serial
Wie kommst du da drauf
Der macht doch jetzt
China-Chinesen-Roller
Review-Kram
Nicht Mikroweich
Mini-Mini-Weich
Also sobald einer Win doof sagt
Ist das für mich so der
Der Mega-Boomer-Indicator
Da weißt du Bescheid
Und
Und wisst ihr
Die gleichen Leute
Die sagen auch nicht Mehrwertsteuer
Sondern Märchensteuer
Da hat mich der Chat drauf gebracht
Aber das ist wirklich so
Kennt ihr so Leute
Das ist wirklich so
Das ist ein heftiger Boomer-Indicator
Ja
Die ist mir auch
Letzten schon aufgefallen
Die Partei für Schulmedizinische
Verjüngungsforschung
Wobei
Mein Wahl-O-Mat-Ergebnis war ja eh etwas weird
Ich sollte irgendwelche
5G
Skeptiker wählen
Wisst ihr doch
Ich sollte die übelsten Keck-Alo-Leute wählen
Wobei der Wahl-O-Mat ja nicht sagt
Was man wählen soll
Sondern nur
Womit man insgesamt prozentual
Die meisten Übereinstimmung hatte
Und vielleicht habe ich einfach zu
Ja
Weird abgestimmt
Zu weit auseinanderliegend
Dass nur solche merkwürdigen Parteien das hatten
Also
Also mein Ergebnis von meinem Wahl-O-Mat war
Der Höchste hatte tatsächlich
Nur 77%
Und ich habe mich nicht mehr
Und das waren irgendwelche Keck-Alo
5G Skeptiker
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen
Wie die hießen
Die wurden
Witzigerweise die wurden auch während Corona-Zeit
Während der Corona-Zeit gegründet
Und da sind wahrscheinlich auch irgendwelche
Die Bill Gates nicht mögen wegen Mikrochips
Und so
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen wie die heißen die ich wählen soll
Laut dem Wahl-O-Mat
Aber die stehen skeptisch 5G gegenüber
Mehrwertsteuer
Ja
Wie gesagt die gleichen Leute sagen auch Wendow
Weißt du was das
Weißt du was das Schlimme daran ist
Das Problem hat dein Vater
Aber
Das gleiche Problem könnte heute auch
Ein 12-Jähriger haben
Da habe ich auch teilweise den Eindruck
Also das muss ich anders sagen
Noch
Also als ich mal
Ich mache jetzt
Den Kr PA masuk
Und dann
krasses Boomer-Antwort ever für euch.
Als ich mal in eurem Alter
war, ja,
also als ich mal so, keine Ahnung,
13, 14, 15
war,
ihr seid älter, ich weiß,
als ich mal so 14 rum
war, da hab ich mir Gedanken gemacht,
okay, wie wird denn das eigentlich in Zukunft
sein? Und da war ich mir sehr
sicher, wirklich, du hättest mich von
nix anderem überzeugen, aber ich war sehr sicher,
dass jede weitere Generation,
die nach mir kommt,
noch mehr Plan von Technik
und Computerkram und Internet
und allem hat, als ich,
weil die ja ganz intuitiv damit
aufwachsen, dass das für die einfach
das Selbstverständlichste auf der
Welt sein wird, ja, ihren Computer
zu bedienen, internetmäßig
sich zu bewegen und
neue Sachen,
ja, neue Sachen
zu lernen, aufzunehmen. Da hab ich
mich aber extrem getäuscht.
Wenn ich mir das angucke,
12-Jährige heute,
haben gefühlt genauso wenig
Plan, wie die,
keine Ahnung, 60-plus-Jährigen.
Die haben
anderweitig,
also, man kann nicht sagen, dass
exakt das Gleiche ist, ja,
ähm, bei den
60-plus-Jährigen hast du dann sowas wie,
oh, warum muss man das so kompliziert machen, man kann
auch einfach auch ein Fax schicken oder,
oh, ich mag das nicht, dass der
Fernseher jetzt so eine komische App hat
dafür und so, das ist das so eher
bei 60 oder zum Beispiel so,
ah, wo ist denn jetzt hier der
Restart-Knopf und sowas in der Richtung,
ja, wie starte ich das jetzt neu?
Früher konntest du den Fernseher einfach ein-
ausschalten, heute muss ich eine App closen und
wieder starten und so. Das ist so eher der 60-jährige
Boomer-Take.
Die haben damit
Probleme, ja.
Ja, aber die jungen Leute
haben mit sowas hier dann teilweise Probleme.
Wo du denkst,
ey, wo ist das Problem?
Dann geh an deinen
Desktop, installiere das und
benutze das.
Aber das hat doch kein App Store.
Wie soll das gehen ohne
App Store?
Geh einfach auf die Webseite, klick das an und so.
Ja, aber
wie mache ich das denn?
Die sind anderweitig lost.
Gerade auch bei
Internet- und PC-Problemen heutzutage, ja.
Letztens
hat mich tatsächlich, da war ich
echt komplett verwirrt.
Ich bin, ich bin,
ich bin langgelaufen bei uns.
Zum, ich glaube,
zum Rewe, ja.
Bin ich langgelaufen
und da läuft man an so einer, an so einem,
an so ein paar Wohnsiedlungen vorbei
und irgendwo da in der Ecke ist auch eine Schule
und dann fragt
mich irgendein, keine Ahnung,
10-Jähriger, 12-Jähriger,
wissen Sie, wo es hier zur
XYZ-Schule geht?
Und da gucke ich ihn an,
denke mir so,
ja, irgendwo da vorne,
dann...
Hast, hast du nicht Google Maps auf dem Handy?
Ach so, ja, hab ich.
Da hab ich auch...
Hä?
Man hat ein Handy auf dem Kopf, Google Maps.
Also, da denke ich mir teilweise,
die Leute sind heute so, mit so
ultra-banalen Dinger, teilweise lost, ja.
Und bei den 60-plus-Jährigen-Boomern
wäre das Problem anders,
gewesen.
Die hätten vielleicht noch gecheckt,
dass sie ja ein Handy haben,
aber sie hätten nicht gewusst, wie sie es bedienen müssen.
Aber auch so ein Ding,
so ein typisches Beispiel,
wo ich mir früher gedacht hab,
das ist heute ganz selbstverständlich,
ja, sind Leute
heutzutage, die, sagen wir mal,
Online-Spiele spielen.
Was ist denn gerade der neueste Hype bei jungen Leuten?
Fortnite ist es ja auf jeden Fall nicht mehr.
Was ist denn gerade so, dass,
dass, dass,
ähm,
was kommt denn eigentlich nach Zuma?
Das, was ist denn so gerade so das, das Zuma-Game?
Fortnite nicht mehr.
Valorant?
Näääh.
Valorant, Valorant glaube ich nicht.
Valorant ist eher was für die Gamer-Grills.
TikTok.
Clash of...
Ja, irgendwelches dumme Mobile-Sie...
Ja, aber sagen wir mal, sagen wir mal Valorant, ja.
Oder sagen wir mal Valorant oder, oder, oder Fortnite.
Das ist ja vollkommen egal.
Vielleicht spielen ja manche auch CS.
Minecraft, Minecraft immer noch.
Ja, das stimmt.
Zumindest...
Eine Sache, wo ich früher fest davon überzeugt war, ist,
dass die Leute, die heute in dem Alter sind, ja,
die Fortnite spielen und so,
die dann sich Frankfurt am Südbahnhof vor die Straßenbahn stellen,
um den Loser-Dance zu machen und so.
Das war eines der größten Grinch-Momente ever,
die ich je gesehen habe.
Zumindest...
Ich hab damals gedacht,
für die ist vollkommen klar,
wenn es beispielsweise ruckelt und laggt,
was der Unterschied ist.
Ist es nicht.
Die Leute checken es heute noch nicht.
Ich dachte mir, ey, das ist einfach vollkommen selbstverständlich und logisch
für jemanden, der 2024 Computerspiele spielt,
dass er den Unterschied instinktiv kapiert,
zwischen lag und ruckelt zum Beispiel, ja.
Oder auch diese Geschichte mit, ey...
Das muss irgendwie an mir liegen,
dass es laggt und sowas in der Richtung.
Nee.
Zum größten Teil liegt das irgendwo auf der Strecke dazwischen,
am Server, ansonsten was.
Die dann irgendwelche komischen Tutorials machen auf...
Ähm...
Die sich dann irgendwelche komischen Tutorials auf YouTube angucken,
um Ping-Loss festzustellen.
Leute, ich hab ne...
Ich hab...
Das ist jetzt kein Witz, ja.
Es gibt Tutorials auf YouTube,
die beschreiben, wie man Ping-Loss feststellt.
Passt mal auf.
Und zwar so.
RacerootAliExpress.com
Oh nein!
Ping...
Packet-Loss!
Oh nein, Leute!
Ganz schrecklich!
Packet-Loss!
Und dann flappen sie aus.
IP-Leak MonkaS.
Und dann drehen sie...
Da drehen sie durch, ja.
Es gibt...
Das ist jetzt kein Witz.
Es gibt Tutorials.
Die...
Die zeigen dir sowas.
Zum Packet-Loss feststellen.
Das ist absolut komplett Banane.
Das hat absolut nichts mit Packet-Loss zu tun.
Null!
Null Komma!
Gar nichts hat das mit Packet-Loss zu tun.
Ja, wir können das auch...
Weiß jemand die Option für kontinuierliches Traceroute?
Gibt's doch auch so ein Tool für...
Oder kann das Traceroute sogar selbst?
Ich mach das zu selben.
Ähm...
Ja.
Es gibt so ein...
Es gibt so ein kontinuierliches Traceroute mit Terminal-UI.
Und das zeigt dir dann das halt an.
Und dann...
Genau, das mein ich.
Ja, ja.
MTR, glaub ich.
Ja.
Ja, ja.
MTR.
Es können auch Traceroute-T sein.
Ich weiß nicht was da...
Ne, das ist...
Das ist...
Ne, Moment.
TOS!
Monka TOS!
Ne, das ist irgendwas anderes.
MTR.
Wie geht das jetzt?
AliExpress.com
Ja.
Fuck, Leute!
Packet-Loss!
OMG!
Mein Internet ist kaputt!
91!
99% Packet-Loss!
Ohhhh!
Und dann rasten sie aus und denken sich...
Fuck, mein Internet ist immer...
Früher...
Also, früher war ich mir sicher,
dass Leute, die das 2024 sich angucken, wissen,
dass ihr Internet nicht kaputt ist und sie keinen Packet-Loss haben.
Zumindest...
Leute, überlegt euch jetzt mal...
Seriously.
Überlegt euch mehr ernsthaft.
Ihr hättet einen Packet-Loss
von 97% beim dritten Hop.
Ihr könntet euer Internet nicht benutzen.
Es wird einfach nicht funktionieren.
Ihr würdet nicht einfach mal irgendwelche Schüsse in Fortnite nicht registrieren oder sowas.
Es wäre komplett unbenutzbar.
Und die Frage, die man sich jetzt ja auch stellen muss, ist...
Wenn ich beim dritten Hop schon 98% Packet-Loss hab,
wie kann es dann sein, dass ich beim sechzehnten Hop 0% hab?
Komisch, oder?
Ihr würdet ja eigentlich erwarten, jeder weitere Punkt müsste dann mindestens genauso viel haben.
Ja.
Und...
Und das hätte ich eigentlich erwartet,
dass Leute, 2024 junge Leute,
dass ohne Probleme instinktiv,
weil sie damit aufgewachsen sind,
solche Zusammenhänge verstehen.
Aber es ist nicht so.
Ja, und dann...
Und dann schnappen die Leute irgendwelche Dinger auf,
von Packet-Loss bis Buffer-Bloat oder whatever
und werfen damit um sich in einem Kontext,
der überhaupt nichts damit zu tun hat.
Ja.
Genauso, wenn sie anfangen dann...
der Meinung sind,
oh ja hier,
ich brauch irgendwie...
nen Router mit Gaming-Funktion,
der ein bisschen QoS macht,
aber...
im Prinzip ist ihre Internetverbindung halt zu 0,005% ausgelastet,
aber ich brauch unbedingt QoS.
Hätte ich auch geerwartet früher,
dass die Leute heute instinktiv verstehen,
dass das nur sinnvoll ist,
wenn die Verbindung einen gewissen Auslastungsgrad hat.
Wo nix ist,
musst du keine Warteschlangen haben,
die du dann mit QoS priorisierst,
wenn einfach nix sich aufstaut.
Ja.
Und das sind so Dinger,
wo ich halt echt früher gedacht hätte,
ey, das checkt jeder,
jeder, der 2024 quasi in meinem damaligen Alter ist.
Aber nee.
Das ist so ein Peak gab das.
Meine Generation und die Generation danach,
da gab's so nen Peak in...
Ja, wie soll man sagen...
Endnisstand,
was so...
Computer, Internet,
IT-Technik angeht.
Und dann ging's wieder runter.
Ja.
Die Generation,
meine Generation,
die ist,
die ist genau so gespalten.
Es gibt einmal die Leute,
die in meinem...
Ich mein, ich werd 40 dieses Jahr, ja.
Die in meinem Alter die übelsten Boomer schon sind,
die zum Stammtisch gehen
und da rumflamen
und gerne faxen
und sich darüber beschweren,
dass man jetzt mit ner Krankenkassen-App
sein Zeug angucken kann.
Und so was.
Und dann gibt's die Leute...
Also, das liegt halt daran,
wo die in ihrer Jugend abgebogen sind.
Ja.
Als ich so 14, 15,
12, 13, 14, 15 war,
da konnte man halt,
in meine Generation,
konnte in zwei Richtungen abbiegen.
Ja.
In die klassische Boomer-Richtung,
so old school,
so wir schicken weiter Faxe
und finden alles neue Kacke.
Oder in die Richtung,
in die ich abgebogen bin.
Man interessiert sich für Computer-Kram.
Ja.
Also,
das ist,
das ist auch Computer-Kram,
und Internet und Technik.
Das heißt,
in meiner Generation
gibt es Leute,
die sind so krasse Boomer
wie 60-,
70-Plus.
Oder es gibt Leute wie mich,
die jetzt vielleicht
auch nicht mehr ganz mithalten können
bei den neuesten Zuma-Trends.
Vieles kann ich nicht nachvollziehen,
warum man es geil findet.
Aber ich kann zumindest Twitch-E-Modes,
was richtige Boomer nicht können.
Und die Generation danach,
die war noch,
noch ein bisschen besser,
was Technik angeht,
aber ich,
Und das liegt daran, weil du dich in meiner Generation, also sagen wir mal so, die Generation vor mir, die hat es ja noch, also die paar, die sich dort für Technik interessiert haben, die mussten ja wirklich richtig Low-Level einsteigen.
Die mussten Assembler programmieren oder irgendwelche Dinger zusammen löten oder whatever.
Ja, aber bei meiner Generation wurde das langsam aber sicher Mainstream und die Generation danach noch ein bisschen mehr.
Aber ich glaube, man musste sich, es war noch nicht so simpel, dass man sich gar nicht mehr mit beschäftigen muss.
Heute ist das komplett easy, so die 0815 Sachen zu machen, die eigentlich komplex sind.
Ihr müsst euch mal überlegen, was du mit, also wenn du ein Smartphone hast, also nicht nur was da allein schon an Technik drin steckt.
Wenn man so eine App öffnet wie YouTube.
Was da an riesen Sachen dahinter eigentlich alles funktionieren muss, damit du dir in der YouTube App überhaupt das angucken kannst.
Und das funktioniert heute einfach so gut und, ja sagen wir mal, so intuitiv, dass du außer App installieren auf dem Smartphone da nicht mehr viel für machen musst.
Du musst dir keine Gedanken drüber machen, um die Sachen drumherum.
Und ich glaube, deswegen können die Leute halt sich super, was so Mediensachen angeht, bewegen.
Aber sobald was nicht geht...
Sind, glaube ich, viele Zoomer heute auch sehr lost bei technischen Problemen.
Zwar auf andere Art, wie die Generation vor mir, aber auch.
Auch so ein Ding, manchmal höre ich tatsächlich noch Radio, ja.
Und da sagen die dann sowas durch wie, hier ist bla bla bla Radio 105.8.
Oder denke ich mir so, wenn das irgendein Zoomer hört heute...
Meint ihr, die wissen noch, was mit 105.8 überhaupt gemeint ist?
Frequenzen einstellen an einem Radio?
Was soll das überhaupt sein?
Du machst die App auf, auf deinem Handy von dem Radio und es geht halt.
Musst nicht an einem Radio eine Frequenz einstellen.
Ach, das juckt.
Was ist ein Zoomer?
Alles, was jünger ist als ich.
So genaue Definitionen gibt es ja nicht.
Genauso wie es keine genaue Definition für Boomer gibt.
Man muss sagen, klar, viele sagen, ja, das ist die Baby-Boomer-Generation, aber ist ja gar nicht so wirklich, ja.
Mit Boomer ist eigentlich alles gemeint, was so das typische Boomer-Verhalten aufweist.
So, ich mag Technik nicht, ich schick lieber Faxe, ich will nicht, dass mein Fernseher eine App hat.
Ich geh zum Stammtisch und kotz mich über Windräder aus.
Und solche Dinger.
Ja, das ist so die ersten Sachen, die mir so einfallen.
Genau.
Boomer ist keine Generation, sondern irgendwie so eine Lebenseinstellung.
Genau, genau.
Genauso wie ich letztens auf Twitter gelernt hab, dass Weißsein auch keine Hautfarbe ist, sondern eine Einstellung.
Da hab ich mir auch gedacht, okay, genug Twitter für heute.
Sorry, sorry, genug X, genug X.com für heute.
Ich mach wieder aus.
Ja, und weil die halt, glaub ich, auch zum größten Teil am Smartphone hängen.
Was nicht schlimm ist, ich mein, jeder, was er fürs tägliche Leben braucht, ja.
Wie nennt sich eigentlich dann die Generation nach Z?
Fängt das dann wieder bei A an?
Ruckel und Lag ist ein Unterschied, ja.
Ruckeln ist bei dir performancebedingt auf dem Rechner.
Ich mein, ja, bevor jetzt die Leute wieder ankommen, actually, Max, das kann auch das eine durch das andere.
Ja, es gibt auch Spiele, die ruckeln dadurch, dass der Server nicht schnell genug hinterherkommt.
Aber das ist meistens ein deutlich anderes Ruckeln als performancebasiertes Ruckeln.
Ja, also wenn jetzt irgendwie 50.000 Gegner bei dir auf dem Bildschirm angezeigt werden müssen
und deine CPU, GPU und so weiter hinterherkommt, dann hast du performancebedingtes Ruckeln bei dir auf dem Rechner.
Ja, wenn du damit 5 FPS rumruckelst.
Also hat nichts damit zu tun, ob beispielsweise der Server nicht mehr hinterherkommt,
die ganzen Daten zu prozessen, Netzwerkprobleme dazwischen sind.
Es gibt einmal, sagen wir mal, das Server-Netzwerkbasierte.
Das ist das, was man eigentlich normalerweise unter Lag versteht.
Und es gibt Ruckeln.
Ruckeln.
Ruckeln ist für mich eigentlich Client-basierte Performanceprobleme und Lag ist für mich Netzwerk-schräglich-Server-Probleme.
Und das kannst du eigentlich in der Regel auch ganz gut unterscheiden.
Wenn du nicht alles automatisch als Lag abstempelst.
Übrigens, wusstet ihr, dass Vodafone jetzt Super-WLAN hat?
Ja.
Richtig.
Ach ja, und wisst ihr, was Super-WLAN ist?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das ist nicht Wi-Fi 7 oder so.
Es ist im Prinzip das.
Zumindest.
Zum Teil, ja.
Es ist im Prinzip das, was jeder halbwegs brauchbare, auch nicht Smart-ROM,
es ist das, was jeder halbwegs brauchbare Access-Point macht,
nämlich zu gucken, welche WLAN-Frequenzen, welche Kanäle sind hier in der Umgebung nicht so viel benutzt
und dann schaltet es halt auf diesen Kanal um.
Es ist im Prinzip ein automatisches WLAN-Kanal auswählen.
Aufgrund der Umgebung.
Also das, was seit Jahren, wenn nicht seit Jahrzehnten, die etwas besseren Access-Points,
also es gibt bestimmt schon über 10 Jahre Access-Points, die das machen.
Das ist überhaupt gar nichts Besonderes.
Ja, Unify macht das ewig schon.
Das machen sehr viele ewig schon.
Automatische Kanalauswahl.
Und dementsprechend ist das eigentlich gar nichts Tolles.
Und man fragt sich eher, warum macht das das Vodafone-Ding nicht,
standardmäßig, ohne Super-WLAN.
Das kann doch jede Fritz...
Ich sag doch, das kann, ob sie Fritzbox kann, kann ich persönlich nicht bestätigen.
Ich verwende das WLAN auf meiner Fritzbox nicht,
aber ich würde mich wundern, wenn sie es nicht könnte.
Das kann jeder etwas...
Oder sagen wir mal, es muss doch so kommen,
das kann jeder nicht super billig Access-Point.
Also wenn du jetzt auf Amazon gehst und dir für 8 Euro den billigsten,
den billigsten TP-Link Access-Points...
Gucken wir doch mal, gucken wir mal nach.
TP-Link Access-Point.
Was ist der billigste TP-Link Access-Point, den wir kriegen?
Hier, beste.
So, 18 Euro.
So, wie kriegen wir jetzt raus, ob der das kann?
Oh, fuck.
Das ist ja, das ist ja antik, man.
802.11b.
Was war denn das?
1998 oder was?
Ah, nee.
1999.
WLAN-Standard von 1999, okay.
Aber das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Warum soll der dann 300 Mbit pro Sekunde schaffen?
Ich glaube, das Ding ist einfach...
Das stimmt einfach nicht, was da steht.
Ich glaube, das stimmt einfach nicht, was da steht.
Aber...
Kann man sogar per PoE?
Ach, guck mal, der kann doch N.
Ja, das hätte mich jetzt auch gewundert, wenn nicht.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt mal rein, ob der das kann.
Ja?
PDF...
Boah, die Webseite, man.
Gucken, nach was soll ich ihn suchen, ob der das kann?
Automatische Channel-Auswahl.
Wir suchen nach Channel.
Gibt's nicht.
Ähm...
Channel?
Was ist denn das denn schon wieder für ein Schrott?
WLAN-Settings.
Ja, Channel.
Auto!
Der kann das, Leute!
Ein...
Hier.
Auto.
Ein 18-Euro-Access-Point von TP-Link auf Amazon kann das.
Also wir reden hier nicht von einem Premium-Feature, was Vodafone hier anbietet.
Aber super, WLAN.
Das verwirrt übrigens auch ganz viele Leute.
Ja, das hab ich auf Twitter schon gesehen.
Die lassen sich dann vom Support erzählen.
Ah, WLAN-Problem.
Die brauchen super WLAN und whatever.
Okay, Moment.
Ich muss mir nochmal den Werbefilm von Vodafone jetzt angucken.
Du hast zu Hause Probleme mit deinem WLAN?
Dann kauf dir einen ordentlichen WLAN-Access-Point.
Oder zwei.
Ja, in so einem Haus ist es durchaus auch mal sinnvoll, zwei zu platzieren.
Gerade, wenn man den Keller noch mit abdecken will.
... Distanz.
... Dicke Wände oder viele verbundene Geräte können die WLAN-Leistung einschränken.
Die Lösung?
Das neue Vodafone Super-WLAN.
Das Super-WLAN wird an dicken Wänden halt auch überhaupt gar nichts ändern.
Null.
Wenn du richtig fette Betonwände hast, welchen WLAN-Channel du da jetzt ausfüllst.
Ich mein, man muss sagen, 2,4 Gigahertz geht eh schon besser durch Wände als 5 Gigahertz.
Mit der intelligenten Empfangstechnologie für deinen Router sicherst du dir eine super smarte,
super zuverlässige WLAN-Verbindung für all deine Geräte.
Das Software-Update ist in deinem Giga-Zuhause-Tarif inklusive und kann jetzt kostenlos aktiviert werden.
Erzähl ihr auch noch, was das macht?
Du brauchst noch mehr Reichweite?
Dann hol dir bis zu 5...
Den Super-WLAN-Verstärker!
... passende Super-WLAN-Verstärker mit dem neuesten WiFi-6-Standard dazu.
Für nur 2,99 Euro im Monat.
...
Ja gut.
Da brauchst du...
...
Das ist schon nett verkehrt.
Wenn man wirklich das...
Wenn man will, dass es einfach nur im letzten Winkel noch irgendwie geht, kann man da schon
Repeater hinstellen.
Warum nicht?
Am besten sind natürlich zwei Access-Points.
Jeweils mit der gleichen SSID und...
...
Hand-Off von einem Gerät zur anderen funktioniert.
... auf moderner Mesh-Technologie
und erzeugt zusammen mit den Super-WLAN-Verstärkern
ein einheitliches...
Wie genau
soll ein einzelner
Access-Point Mesh-Technologie
machen?
Also, ernst gemeinte Frage, wie das funktionieren soll.
... das WLAN-Netzwerk in deinem
Zuhause. So kannst du
nahtlos und störungsfrei mit deinen
Geräten im Internet surfen.
Super-WLAN ist darauf
programmiert, dein Heimnetz zu optimieren.
Es prüft kontinuierlich deine
WLAN-Verbindungen und verbessert sie automatisch.
So sind stabilere
Übertragungen möglich.
Mit der neuen Super-Connect-App
hast du noch mehr Kontrolle über dein Super-WLAN
und kannst deine Vodafone-Station
oder deine Easybox 805
ganz einfach einrichten.
Die App zeigt dir auch die beste Position
für deinen Verstärker.
Und du kannst damit dein WLAN bequem ein- oder
ausschalten. Das ist ja gar nicht mal...
so verkehrt, wenn das auch funktioniert.
... und die WLAN-Zugangsdaten
im Handumdrehen ändern.
Wie kommuniziert denn die App mit dem
Router dann? Bzw. mit dem Access-Point?
Über Bluetooth oder wie?
Egal, ob du schon Vodafone-Kundin
bist oder es werden willst.
Hol dir jetzt
kostenlos zu deinem
Kabel- oder DSL-Tarif und in wenigen
Schritten Super-WLAN.
Das ist nur für Frauen.
WLAN. Auf vodafone.de
slash super-wlan
oder einfach im Vodafone-Shop
bei dir um die Ecke.
Okay, alles klar.
Also, das, was der Chat
gerade meinte,
das war...
Ich muss mal kurz runterscrollen.
Ja, das können eh nicht viele
nach Problemen ordentlich googeln.
Ja, das ist auch so ein Punkt,
dass es genug Zoomer gibt, die denken,
Snapchat-Bilder sind
wirklich weg, nachdem sie gelöscht wurden.
Keine Möglichkeit, das ist irgendwie anders.
Gleich was zu sagen.
Ich wollte eigentlich noch hier was zu sagen.
Ja, das macht Vodafone schon clever.
Viele Boomer kaufen jetzt
bestimmt neue Geräte wegen dem Super-WLAN.
Das Ding ist, was ich die ganze Zeit
eigentlich sagen wollte damit auch,
nicht nur die Boomer,
die jungen Leute heute auch.
Ich glaube, die einzigen zwei Generationen,
die checken, dass das eigentlich gar nichts Besonderes ist,
und die 1.3
ist meine Generation, die danach
und teilweise ein bisschen die, und noch danach
und vielleicht ein paar teilweise von die davor.
Die Großteil der Zoomer
haben überhaupt keinen Plan.
So, welchen Router kannst du empfehlen?
Fritzbox geht bei mir kaputt.
Oder haben Hardware-Bugs, die ein Beispiel, echt?
Also, die Dinger funktionieren auch in der Regel
recht zuverlässig, da stimmt doch irgendwas nicht bei dir.
Bei einer ist der 2,5 Gigahertz-Sender durchgebrannt.
What?
Okay.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich finde die Fritzbox
als Kombi-Gerät gar nicht schlecht.
Ich habe auch eine, weil ich benutze die auch für VoIP.
Und VoIP möchte man ja eigentlich nicht sehen.
Das kann man natürlich selber machen.
Also SIP und irgendwelche anderen Connection-Dinger.
Ich habe auch eine Fritzbox, und die habe ich seit Jahren schon, die geht.
Wobei ich halt bei meiner Fritzbox
das WLAN nicht verwende dran.
Vielleicht wäre das für dich auch sinnvoll.
Du machst alles mit der Fritzbox,
wofür die gut funktioniert.
Und alles andere nicht.
Also mein WLAN geht über zwei extra Access-Points.
Mit der Fritzbox mache ich im Endeffekt VoIP.
Und ja, meine Fritz-Thermostate-Fritzbox.
Und die für die Heizung sind auch dran angeschlossen.
Ich glaube, das war es zum Großen und Ganzen,
was das Ding macht.
Ich habe auch nur eine billige Fritzbox.
Die hat sogar nur 100 Mbit-Anschlüsse.
So alt ist sie schon.
Mir ist kein anderer Kombi-Router bekannt,
der alles das kann, was die Fritzbox kann.
Und gleichermaßen
auch so zuverlässig und gut funktioniert.
Was es bei dir ja nicht macht.
Und gut zu bedienen ist.
Die Dinger sind schon nicht schlecht.
Ich habe früher auch gerne drüber gelästert.
Aber als Kombi-Gerät
für Leute,
die sich nicht so sehr damit beschäftigen wollen,
ist das eigentlich ziemlich nice.
Nichts, solange ich mich nicht
drum kümmern muss.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ob das nichts mit der Generation zu tun hat.
Ich meine, guck mal, die Leute vor mir,
die Generation vor mir,
da gab es noch keine Computer daheim.
Wie sollten die sich groß damit beschäftigen?
Und dementsprechend, wie sollten die feststellen,
dass sie sich dafür interessieren?
Heute sieht es doch ganz anders aus.
Heute hat jeder einen Computer daheim,
jeder Smartphones, Tablets.
Also heute ist die Berührung mit der Technik
doch deutlich größer als früher.
Keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich kannst du dagegen klagen,
du wirst aber keine Chance haben.
Können kann man viel.
Im Zweifelsfall steht das bestimmt auch in den
Nutzerbedingungen drin,
dass die Nachrichten auf unbestimmte Zeit
gespeichert werden dürfen.
Dann gehen halt die Nachrichten an WhatsApp ab
oder sowas.
Ja, gibt es auch.
Ja, das sind dann aber nicht die typischen
Fortnite-Spieler.
So, mal gucken, ob es mittlerweile wieder
Package-Updates gibt,
weil wir haben ja schon eine halbe Stunde
keine Package-Updates mehr gemacht.
Arch, by the way.
Nee, okay, gut.
Danke für den Sub.
Boah, die Subscriptions heute hier.
Ein Schlagaufschlag.
Excellent. Massive Subscriptions.
Nicht so komisch, warte mal.
So.
Wahrscheinlich einfach, weil er kalt ist.
Gut, lass uns mal auf YouTube reingucken,
was haben wir denn so?
Was verdient ein Band?
Okay, komm, wir gucken das neue Fireship-Video,
Leute.
Weil Fireship-Videos sind immer nice.
Die 200 ständigen Verbindungsabbrüche,
weil VDSL, weil der Prozessor...
Oh, Schrott.
Ja, vielleicht ist dann tatsächlich
eine neue Fritzbox gar nicht so verkehrt.
Da hättest du was zu kaufen, bevor man enttäuscht wurde.
Aber insgesamt sind die Dinger echt nicht übel.
Yesterday the clouds opened up
and a weird new programming language came down to earth
with a promise of parallelism
for all thou who writeth code.
This is big, if true, because parallel computing
is a superpower.
Yesterday the clouds opened up
and a weird new programming language came down to earth
with a promise of parallelism
for all thou who writeth code.
This is big, if true, because parallel computing
is a superpower.
To take a problem that could be solved in a week
and instead solve it in seven days
using seven different computers.
Logisch, das ist genauso wie
zwei Frauen bringen das Kind
in der Hälfte der Zeit zur Welt.
Fortunately, running code in parallel
is like conducting a symphony.
One wrong note, and the entire thing becomes a total disaster.
But luckily, Bend offers hope
by making a bold promise.
Everything that can run in parallel
will run in parallel.
You don't need to know anything about CUDA, blocks, LOCKs,
haben wir schon drüber gesprochen, letzten Stream, ja, sehr nice.
Ich fürchte, da muss ich kurz was zu sagen, so nice das ist, dass vor allem Workstation jetzt kostenlos ist für Privatanwender,
ich fürchte, das ist ein Zeichen dafür, dass vor allem Workstation aufs Abstellgleis gestellt wird.
Es hat sich letzten Jahre über schon an vor allem Workstation wenig getan und jetzt ist halt die Frage, ob sich da überhaupt noch was dran tun wird.
Was sehr bedauerlich wäre, weil vor allem Workstation die beste Desktop-Virtualisierungstechnologie ist und wir brauchen ordentliche Desktop-Virtualisierung.
Dass man zum Beispiel sowas hier machen kann.
Ja, und Threading in Python ist so merkwürdig, irgendwie, ich hab mich damit nur am Rande beschäftigt,
aber ich lese.
Also immer, wenn man, wenn man ums Thema, ähm, Multithreading und Python sich anguckt, da hast du immer sau viele Fallstricke.
Es gibt irgendwie drei Möglichkeiten, was zu machen und das eine ist dann tatsächlich, äh, nur unter der Haube Multithreader, dabei ist es weiterhin eigentlich auf ein Core und das andere ist super weird, auf jeden Fall.
There's all kinds of gotchas, like race conditions, deadlocks, thread starvation, and may even lead to conflicts with demons.
Even if you do manage to get it working, you might find that your CPU just doesn't have the bandwidth for it.
Ja, komplett random.
Natürlich.
Was? Hat jemand mit irgendeiner anderen Programmiersprache gerechnet?
Lasingly fast.
Ja, wenn dein Hirn es schafft.
Auf die Kaffeekarte.
Und wieder einmal, ich kann diesen Code ohne Modifikation auf CUDA.
Und vielleicht auch Sachen, von denen du in deinem Hirn gar nicht weißt, dass sie sich gut parallelisieren lassen.
Stell dir mal vor, du hast jetzt irgendwas, irgendeinen kleinen Teil deiner Anwendung, der halt sauviel CPU-Leistung braucht.
Und den lagerst du aus in ein Band-Programm.
Ja, lässt das kompilieren, whatever.
Rufst das über irgendeinen C-Interface auf.
Und dann macht es das einfach in parallel.
Das könnte richtig nice sein.
Das kann nicht nur Recursion, das kann nur Recursion, wenn ich das richtig verstehe.
...with bendrun-cu.
And now this code only takes one and a half seconds to run.
And I'll just go ahead and drop the mic right there.
This has been the Code Report. Thanks for watching.
Okay, dann müssen wir gleich mal gucken.
Bend, F-F-I-C.
Bend, Lang, Witch.
Massively Parallel High-Level Programming Language.
Ja, also, so wie ich das verstanden habe, wandelt der das um, bis dort ganz viele parallelisierbare Instruktionen rauskommen.
Ich habe außer dem Video bis jetzt auch noch nichts dazu geguckt.
Okay, ähm, kann man?
Currently not working on Windows. Ja, ist mir egal.
Also, ich würde jetzt vermuten, dass die...
...das Band selber nicht...
...nicht unter Windows funktioniert, aber dass der Output, also dann die Library oder das Binary, dass das auch schon unter Windows funktioniert, oder?
Kann man...
Kann man Bend-Programme irgendwie per...
...ansprechen aus anderen...
Aha, kann man noch nicht.
Okay, ist aber geplant.
Moment, Moment, mir geht's jetzt nicht darum.
Okay, man kann Bend wohl noch nicht ansprechen aus anderen Sprachen.
Das...
...doch, oder?
Ja, das müssen wir mal beobachten.
Es hört sich echt ganz spannend an.
Was dann nochmal so toll jetzt kann...
Also, so wie ich das verstehe, kannst du damit halt Probleme, von denen du in deinem Hirn nicht in der Lage bist, sie ordentlich zu parallelisieren, parallelisieren lassen.
Alternativ, äh, nicht nur auf der CPU ausführen, sondern eben direkt auch auf einer Grafikkarte.
Was das nicht einfach nur doppelt, dreifach, vierfach, fünffach, sechzehnfach so schnell macht, sondern tausendfach so schnell.
Nee, das hat mit PyTorch nix zu tun.
Das finde ich ganz spannend.
Also, das müssen wir uns mal im Hinterkopf behalten.
So, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch?
Das...
Oh, das gucke ich immer gerne.
Das ist immer so, so unsinnig überflüssig, aber nett anzugucken.
Yesterday.
Das haben wir uns doch schon angeschaut jetzt.
Man kann die Grafikkarte anstelle der CPU benutzen.
Also, wenn...
Also, wie ich das verstanden habe...
...kannst du ein Programm in BEND programmieren oder ein Problem in BEND beschreiben, wie auch immer man es besser nennt.
Was schon mal den Vorteil hat, dass du dir ums Parallelisieren selbst keine Gedanken machen musst.
Also, du musst dir nicht selbst überlegen, wie kannst du es parallelisieren.
Du schreibst das mehr oder weniger so, wie du dir es denkst.
BEND parallelisiert das für dich, also transformiert deinen Code so, dass er gut parallelisierbar ist.
Und dann kannst du ihn entweder Single-Threaded ausfüllen, Multi-Threaded auf der CPU oder super krass Multi-Threaded auf der GPU.
Das ist keine AI-Version.
Der hört sich schon immer so an.
Schon bevor es AI gab.
Aber der hat seine Stimme mittlerweile, glaube ich, ver...
Wie heißt das?
Versprach-Modeln lassen, dass andere Leute Videos machen können, die sich so anhören wie er.
Ne, das wird nicht funktionieren.
Du kannst dann wahrscheinlich BEND aus JavaScript aufrufen.
In demnächst.
Was sicherlich für so Unternehmen wie Discord beispielsweise ganz cool ist, ja.
Und das jetzt mal...
Stellt euch mal vor, Discord würde irgendein Feature anbieten, was super krass CPU-intensiv ist.
Mir fällt jetzt leider kein gescheites Beispiel an.
Ja, gehen wir mal von aus, Discord würde irgendwie anbieten...
Was könnte Discord denn anbieten, was super, super krass GPU-intensiv ist?
Und was nicht AI-Zeug ist.
Ja, Statistik oder sowas.
Ja, gehen wir mal von aus, Discord würde irgendwie anbieten, dass ihr irgendwelche Message-Statistiken oder whatever machen könnt.
Und das machen die nicht Server-seitig bei sich, sondern bei euch auf dem Kleinen.
Und jedes Mal, wenn ihr das macht, müsst ihr fünf Minuten warten, bis Discord fertig ist.
Und die könnten jetzt, die könnten quasi diesen Part in BEND programmieren.
Könnten dann das aufrufen.
Und es wird entweder auf eurer GPU ausgeführt, wenn die supportet ist, oder multithreaded auf eurer CPU.
Und das ist dann nicht in fünf Minuten fertig, sondern in drei Sekunden.
Ich glaube nicht, dass ein Bitcoin-Miner ein gutes Beispiel ist für...
Na doch, könnte zumindest, zumindest der Hash-Such-Part könnte eventuell nice sein dafür.
Wobei Bitcoin halt eh unsinnig ist, auf GPUs und CPUs zu minen.
Aber das muss man sich mal im Hinterkopf behalten.
Ich finde, das ist eine coole Sache.
Org.
So, komm, wir gucken jetzt.
Six Lego Vehicles vs. Six Obstacles.
Obstacles. Obstacles. Ich kann das nicht aussprechen.
Hindernisse. Sagen wir einfach mal.
Obstacles.
Alter, High-IQ-Konstruktion schon mal, ey.
Aaaah. Ja, nice. Easy.
Easy.
Sieht reichlich umständlich aus, das Drehen.
Ohhhh.
Oh.
Das klappt doch im Leben, wollte gerade sagen.
Also ich glaube, wenn hier ein bisschen, wenn hier ein bisschen Gummi unten an den Füßen wäre, könnte das durchaus funktionieren.
Ne, das klappt nicht.
Gut.
Das Ding sollte mit den Abgründen am Anfang überhaupt kein Problem haben, aber das kommt auch nicht...
Ne, das kommt auch nicht über die Wand drüber.
Glaube ich nicht.
Und wo das Ding richtig Probleme mit haben wird, ist die...
Die Schräge hoch zu rollen oder nicht runter zu rutschen.
Ja, das wird nix.
Ja.
Übrigens, das Ding dürfte laut Flacherdlern ja nicht funktionieren, weil Gravitation und so, das gibt's ja nicht.
Okay.
Das Ding schafft die Schräge wahrscheinlich easy.
Also diese, weil's Gummi-Räder hat.
Ist das sinnlos? Ja, diese Videos sind mega sinnlos.
Ja, aber ich guck die gerne.
Aber was das Ding nicht schafft, ist...
Ja, das schafft's easy.
Was das Ding nicht schafft, ist der normale...
Ja, der normale Graben zwischen den zwei Platten.
Da fällt's runter.
Das schafft's...
...nicht.
Ich hätte gedacht, das schafft's.
Das schafft's, ja, das hätte ich jetzt vermutet.
Ja.
Äh, rumdrehen wird's auch nicht schaffen.
Oder wird's schaffen?
Doch, doch schafft's.
Okay.
Das war eher ein Skill-Issue des Drivers.
Okay, das wird nix.
Okay.
Das Ding sollte keine...
Das hat Gummi und das Ding sollte die Schräge schaffen.
In beide Richtungen.
Die Wand schafft's auf jeden Fall nicht.
Und die Abgründe...
...wird das...
...weiß ich nicht.
Ich frage, ob's lang genug ist.
Okay.
Gibt's?
Das...
Ja, genau.
Das andere scha...
Oh, ob's das...
Ja, das schafft's auch.
Nope.
Nicht easy.
Das schafft's.
Okay.
Da hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht, da ist es geradezu wie gemacht für easy.
Schafft's das.
Aber das ist wahrscheinlich einfach nicht schwer genug.
Hat nicht genug Druck da unten drauf.
Ja, das wird nix.
Korgas.
Leichtes.
Das schafft's auch.
Das...
...ist so kurz.
Aber es sieht so aus, als ist es breiter als das.
Das sollte es auch schaffen, ja.
Nope.
Ja, da ist es nicht schnell genug für.
Und das geht auch nicht.
Ich weiß echt nicht, warum wir uns das angucken.
Aber irgendwie guck ich die Videos geil.
Jetzt wird der advanced shit rausgeholt hier.
Okay, lass mich raten.
Das Ding packt jetzt alles.
Ja, mit den Gummi-Rädern sollte kein...
...sollte kein Problem sein.
Oh, okay.
Das wird's schaffen.
Das ist ja quasi gemacht dafür.
Das...
Das muss schneller sein.
In der Geschwindigkeit klappt es nicht.
Aber mit ein bisschen Schmackes, wie man so schön sagt hier, geht das.
Okay, mal gucken, was als nächstes kommt.
Ach nee, das wird jetzt verbessert.
Okay.
Ich hätte es gedacht, er macht's einfach schneller, dass das da...
Ups, dass das da rüberspringen kann.
Passt mal auf.
Mit den fetten Rädern packt's jetzt irgendwas anderes nicht mehr.
Ja.
Speed.
Boah, Action pur.
Hä, das sag ich doch.
Es packt jetzt irgendwas anderes nicht mehr.
Mich hätte jetzt interessiert, wenn es kleinere Räder hätte.
Wieder die kleinen Räder, aber mehr Geschwindigkeit, ob's dann einfach gehen würde.
Er hat's schneller gemacht und größere Räder dran.
Also er hat quasi die Übersetzung ausgetauscht an den Rädern und die Räder.
Und, und, äh, fettere, stärkere Motoren draufgemacht.
Ahhhh.
Knapp.
Ja.
Und, und, äh, fettere, stärkere Motoren draufgemacht.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Guck mal hier!
Alter.
Ach komm, lassen wir ihn gucken.
Das ist ein kompletter...
Och nicht schon wieder so ein Ding.
... Home-Server beziehungsweise NAS mit 10 TB Speicherkraft.
Das ist doch ganz normal.
Boah.
Die Dinger gibt es doch
im laufenden Band überall mittlerweile.
Das war bei denen noch nicht, aber...
Habe ich mir selbst zusammen gebastelt?
Sogar ich hatte mal so ein Teil
bei mir auf dem Channel.
Wobei, nicht so ein Teil, das stimmt nicht.
Ich hatte eins mit
ähm
Top Ryzen CPU und Grafikkarte
für Emulationskram.
Das ist so ein passiv gekühles
Ding. Na gut, wie kriegst du denn
so ein kleines Teil 10 Terabyte rein?
Im Prinzip
hast du Platz
für eine NVMe
SSD eventuell?
Äh SATA?
Ist die Frage, wie viel?
Weil rein, also mit zwei Sachen
geht das, aber wird knapp.
Da musst du ja jeweils 4 Terabyte
SSDs machen, das wird dann
geht dann ins
also sofern da nicht noch eine dritte rein
passt.
...Gehäuse und Mainboard
sind von AliExpress.
Ja und das Teil kann ich einfach neben
meinen Router stellen.
China-Chinesen-Hardware.
Nicht mehr drüber nachdenken, weil das Ding ist komplett passiv
gekühlt, macht keinen Mux, hat keine
Mellen und nicht mehr drüber nachdenken, weil das Ding
ist komplett passiv gekühlt, macht kein
Das ist bestimmt so ein Teil mit
ähm Intel
J oder
N
4000 irgendwas.
Diese, diese ollen
Embedded CPU
Low Power
Intel Dinger.
Kein Mux, hat keine mechanischen Festplatten,
drin und 10 Terabyte sollten noch ein paar Jahre reichen.
Und schnell genug ist definitiv auch.
Hier lasse ich gerade ein lokales KI-Sprachmodell drauf.
Ja, braucht keinen.
Ja und guck mal, hier kopiere ich gerade eine Datei von meinem Windows-Rechner ab.
Ordentlich.
Okay, also hat das Ding 2,5 Gig Schnittstellen
auf den Home-Server.
290 Megabyte die Sekunde.
Kann man machen, oder?
Na, für Filme ist das nix.
Für Filme ist der SSD-Speicher viel zu teuer.
Ja und wie gesagt, alles komplett passiv gekühlt.
Kein einziger Lüfter eingebaut.
Und die Leistungsaufnahme liegt im Leerlauf bei unter 11.
Was haben so viele kritisiert, dass es nicht redundant ist, dass die Glaube an gepinnten Kommentaren war?
Das würde ich ganz ehrlich, ich guck mir das Video an.
Das ist wahrscheinlich nichts, was ich bei so einem Setup kritisieren würde.
Weil im Zweifelsfall ist, je nachdem, was die damit meinen, ob die sowas wie Raid 1 meinen,
äh, finde ich gar nicht mal so sinnvoll bei sowas.
Ein Backup ist tatsächlich sinniger, ja?
Beispielsweise, äh,
USB, noch ne klassische, ähm, Magnet-Festplatte dran und dort einmal in der Nacht ein AirSync drauf gemacht.
Muss kein AirSync sein, könnt irgend'n x-beliebiges Tool nehmen.
Ist wahrscheinlich die bessere Variante, als den Speicherplatz zu halbieren mit nem Raid.
Was?
Wo ist der Haken, fragt ihr euch?
Ja, seht ihr in diesem Video.
Aber Spoiler schon mal, der Haken ist klein genug, dass ich das Teil auf jeden Fall als
mein Homeserver weiter betreiben werde.
Niemals, niemals, niemals, oh.
Herzlich Willkommen.
Alter, das ist irren Träumer.
Dieses Video wird gesponsert von Corderware.
Corderware Best Zero verbindet Menschen mit ihren Apps, egal, ob ihr nun digitale Nomaden,
Dienstleister oder Unternehmens-Admins seid.
Mit Best Zero könnt ihr einfach und sicher auf Anwendungen zugreifen und diese anderen
bereitstellen.
Und wenn ihr jetzt denkt, ja, okay, per VPN oder was, nee, Corderware Best Zero ist kein
V-
Ich skip.
VPN, sondern einfach das Thema High-
Genau.
Ja.
Sehe ich genauso.
Chat.
Homeserver schrägstrich nass.
Finde ich persönlich zurzeit super spannend und wenn ich eure Kommentare richtig deute,
ihr auch.
Ja, und ich glaube, das liegt auch daran, weil es da viele Fragen gibt.
Eine der Hauptfragen ist, was nimmt man für Hardware für so ein Ding?
Da gibt es bei mir ein ganz wichtiges Kriterium.
Darf das Ding Lärm machen oder nicht?
Bei mir auf jeden Fall nicht.
Also bei mir darf es bisschen Lärm machen, weil ich habe so einen kleinen, habe ich euch
ja schon gezeigt, also so einen kleinen, kleinen abgeschotteten Raum.
Hier sieht man es ja.
Hier geht es rein.
Aber das ist nicht.
Es ist jetzt nicht super schallgedämmt.
Ja, also im Prinzip sind das ein paar dünne, dünne Gipswände und eine Tür.
Also ein bisschen Krach darf es bei mir machen.
Dann hört man das nicht.
Ich kann jetzt da keine.
Ich könnte da kein Playcenter mit 100% Lüftern reinstellen.
Das würde ich hier auch hören.
Ganz persönliches Problem mit den meisten Nassen.
Also wenn man irgendetwas Fertiges kauft, die haben halt immer Lüfter und die laufen
in den meisten.
Die haben auch meistens so kleine, hässliche Lüfter.
Moment, macht das übrigens hier mein AI-Voicefilter?
Macht das das raus, wenn ich Lüftergeräusche nachmache?
Nein, macht es nicht.
Okay.
Ja, und so hören sich ja die ganzen kleinen Furzlüfter an.
Sind das zwölf Millimeter?
Nee.
Was haben die da?
Diese ganz kleinen 20 Millimeter Lüfter.
Die haben billige und kleine Lüfter.
Sind Schrott meistens.
Nervig.
Ja, das, also wenn es die Möglichkeit gibt, immer nice.
... auch permanent.
Und es gibt ja dann viele Leute, die sagen, ja, wenn es dich nervt, stell das Ding noch
in den Keller oder in die Besenkammer.
Aber das ist dann halt der Clash der Lebensrealitäten.
Ich wohne in einer Mietwohnung.
Ich habe keinen Keller mit Steckdose, geschweige denn Internet und eine Besenkammer auch nicht.
Ich habe einen Keller, aber da ist die Luftfeuchtigkeit so hoch, dass ich dem Ding keine, dass ich
das nicht irgendeiner langhaufenden Hardware da dem aussetzen möchte.
An jedem...
Erinnern ihr euch noch daran?
Haben wir das nicht im...
Wo wir gerade dabei sind.
Haben wir das nicht im Stream gemacht?
Den Lüfter in meinem Switch getauscht?
Hm.
Haben wir das nicht im Stream gemacht?
Vielleicht hat es das nicht ins Archiv geschafft, weil ich irgendwas geleakt habe oder so vielleicht.
Ja, und zwar, ich habe ja so ein ES16XG und da habe ich mir eigene Adapter gedruckt, 3D
gedruckt.
Ja, ja.
Genau so.
Genau so haben wir das.
Das habe ich...
Genau das habe ich gemacht bei mir.
Ja.
Genau das.
Und ich bilde mir ein, das haben wir in einem Stream gemacht.
Ja.
Genau das haben wir in einem Stream gemacht.
Ich bilde mir ein, das haben wir im Stream gemacht.
Es kann auch sein, dass ich es ein bisschen durcheinander bringe.
Ja, und da konnte man dann die größeren Oktur-Lüfter da drauf machen.
Weil so kleine gab es keine.
Hast du echte UniFi-Hardware im Einsatz?
Das ist keine UniFi-Hardware.
Das ist ein Edge-Switch.
Das ist eines mit eigener Management-Oberfläche und nicht UniFi-Crap.
Ich habe alles UniFi-mäßige rausgeschmissen in der Zwischenzeit.
Und den hier hatte ich schon, bevor ich überhaupt mit UniFi-Sachen angefangen habe.
Das ist ein Edge-Switch.
Das ist eines mit eigener Management-Oberfläche und nicht UniFi-Crap.
Ich habe alles UniFi-mäßige rausgeschmissen in der Zwischenzeit.
Und den hier hatte ich schon, bevor ich überhaupt mit UniFi-Sachen angefangen habe.
Das ist eines der besten Netzwerk-Hardware-Sachen, die ich mir in den letzten Jahren gekauft
habe.
Das Ding funktioniert einfach.
War vor die damalige Zeit gar nicht mal so teuer.
Na klar kann man sich jetzt darüber beschweren, 500 Euro sind ja nicht so viel.
Aber ich habe es schon.
Ich habe es schon.
Nicht das gleiche, ne.
Das eine ist der Hersteller, das andere ist quasi eine Marke
vom Hersteller.
Edge Switch ES
ist genauso eine Marke wie Unify.
Ja, und das habe ich bei mir auch
im Switch laufen.
Und ja, man kann den Switch danach noch zumachen.
Zumindest meiner ist zu.
Was hast du gegen Unify?
Oh, ich habe eigentlich
nichts wirklich großartig gegen Unify.
Ich mag es einfach nicht.
Also, eine Sache,
die mich bei Unify
nervt, ist, dass sie auf der einen Seite sich an
Heim-Anwender
richten wollen und auf der einen Seite
so, sagen wir mal, möglichst easy
machen.
Aber das nicht konsequent.
Und dann Sachen
anders benennen,
als man es erwarten würde,
eher im Profi-Umfeld.
Also, ich fand
das nie, das ist natürlich sehr subjektive
Sache, ne. Ich fand das nie schlüssig
von der Aufmachung her, Unify.
Und das größte Problem,
was ich mit Unify hatte,
war gar nicht das, sondern
dass die Features,
die andere Hersteller schon
lange haben, ewig
nicht unterstützt haben. Und das Hauptfeature,
was mich wirklich sehr genervt
hat und sehr gewurmt hat,
dass Unify das nicht
hat, ist,
für das gleiche WLAN
mehrere Passwörter
vergeben für unterschiedliche Geräte. Also, sprich,
dass man ein WLAN-Blub hat,
ein SSID-Blub, ja.
Aber ich möchte,
dass Gerät 1 das Passwort
123456 hat und Gerät 2
ABCDEFG
als Passwort hat. Für das gleiche
WLAN. Und das ist
ein Feature, das können die meisten anderen
Hersteller, die jetzt, also wir reden jetzt nicht
vom 16, 18 Euro
billig TP-Link Access Point,
aber alle etwas besseren
Hersteller können das, außer Unify.
Unify kann es mittlerweile
auch seit 3, 4,
4 Jahren oder so.
Aber da hatte ich schon rausgeschmissen.
Das hat mich wirklich genervt, weil das
wollte ich unbedingt haben
und Unify hat es einfach jahrelang nicht
auf die Reihe gekriegt, obwohl das alle anderen
Hersteller, sogar MikroTik
mit ihren, sogar mit den billigen Access Points
kann das. Wobei ich glaube,
dass die MikroTik-Implementierung ein bisschen
hakelig ist, aber
dafür ist das Gramm deutlich günstiger.
OpenWrt kann es mittlerweile übrigens
auch ganz brauchbar.
Ich weiß nicht, ob über das Webinterface oder
nur über dieses WPA-File,
aber wenn
OpenWrt das auf einem Billig-Router kann,
dann würde ich sagen, ey, sowas
dürfte Unify auch einbauen,
obwohl es dazu ja
schon ganz
lange Feature-Requests
gab.
Und die wollten
einfach nicht.
Mittlerweile kann es Unify,
aber es ist sehr praktisch,
ein
WLAN zu haben, mit
mehreren Passwörtern.
Zum Beispiel, wenn ihr viele IoT-Geräte,
Matrix HD, danke für den Sub,
zum Beispiel, wenn ihr viele
IoT-Geräte habt,
dann braucht ja jedes
IoT-Gerät quasi euer
WLAN-Passwort.
Und wenn es da nur ein
WLAN-Passwort gibt, dann habt ihr halt
das Problem, wenn ihr das mal ändern
wollt, dann müsst ihr das auf
allen Geräten ändern,
was teilweise Ding der Unmöglichkeit ist,
wenn man irgendwie 60 IoT-Geräte hat,
und die sonst wo verteilt hat.
Und wenn ihr eines dieser Geräte mal wegschmeißt,
dann liegt quasi weiterhin
im Flash
von diesem Gerät irgendwo
in eurem Müll euer WLAN-Passwort.
Zwei Sachen, die ich nicht schön
fand,
und was man halt mit
mehreren WLAN-Passwörtern
pro Gerät, fürs
gleiche WLAN wohlgemerkt,
easy ändern kann.
Und viele Hersteller es auch schon unterstützen,
aber
äh,
bei Unify hat man sich da einfach
jahrelang Zeit gelassen, und es sah so aus,
als wird das nie unterstützt.
Bis es, bis irgendwann vor einem dreiviertel Jahr
oder so, dass wir einen Firmware-Update eingefügt haben.
Ja, wenn man mehrere Sachen verwaltet,
ist das sicherlich cool, dass man
mehrere Standorte und mehrere
Gebäudeinstallationen und sowas
da drüber verwaltet.
Für diesen Verwaltungsaspekt mag das ganz cool sein,
aber das, ja,
trifft für mich hier im Haus mit ein paar Access Points,
macht's das nicht aus.
Zumal,
die Access Points, die ich jetzt habe,
die haben auch
ein Management-Dashboard, aber halt
Build-In in den Access Points.
Warum sollten, hä?
Das, was juckt der, was juckt den Access Point,
ob du nen Shielded oder nicht Shielded Kabel hast?
Sperrst du auch den Internetzugriff der Geräte?
Kommt drauf an, in welchem WLAN du drinne bist.
Wenn du im
IoT-WLAN bist,
dann darfst du nicht ins Internet.
Bei mir dürfen Geräte im IoT-WLAN,
weder miteinander reden,
noch mit dem Internet reden.
Die dürfen nur sich connecten auf den MQTT-Server,
wenn sie die Credentials für haben.
Und auf NTP.
NTP-Zeile abrufen dürfen sie auch,
weil sonst haben manche Geräte Probleme.
Das ist das einzige, was bei mir im IoT-WLAN erlaubt ist.
Und wenn ich ein Gerät wegschmeiße,
dann wird das einfach gelöscht.
Und dann kann ich's wegschmeißen.
Easy.
Easy as fuck.
Okay. Das ist aber sehr merkwürdig.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das den jetzt überhaupt interessiert,
was für eine Sorte Kabel daran angeschlossen ist.
So. Gucken wir mal weiter.
... würde mich ein permanent rauschendes NAS
beziehungsweise Home-Server doll nerven.
Ja, ich auch.
Wer aber natürlich in so einem Einfamilienhaus wohnt,
der oder die kann sich da vielleicht schlecht eindenken,
weil da gibt's halt genug Orte,
wo man sowas aufstellen kann.
Ich wohne in einem Einfamilienhaus
und ich hab auch keinen gescheiten Ort gehabt,
deswegen musste ich einen bauen.
Lassen.
... ist nachvollziehbar.
Ist halt ein unterschiedliches Nutzungsszenario.
Naja, aber worauf ich hinaus will,
ich hab halt nicht so viel Platz
und am allerliebsten hätte ich halt einen Server.
Ja, aber was interessiert die das überhaupt?
Also, warum kann ein Gerät überhaupt
irgendwie das feststellen,
ob das ein geschirmtes Kabel ist oder nicht?
Weil ich mein, entweder legt an den passenden Pins
POE-Zeug
48 Volt an oder nicht.
Also, warum interessiert die das überhaupt,
ob das Kabel geschildet ist oder nicht?
... den ich mir einfach neben meinen Router
klatsche, Kabel dran und
dann nie wieder drüber nachdenken.
Zurzeit nutze ich einen gebrauchten,
passiv gekühlten FinClient,
an dem ein USB-Hub mit vier
2,5 Zoll 5TB-Platten hängen.
Das ist okay,
weil sich da kein Lüfter dreht
und die Platten sich runterfahren,
wenn sie länger nicht angesprochen werden,
aber elegant ist das nicht,
allein weil die Konstruktion so viel Platz einnimmt.
Außerdem ist mir das Kopieren auf das System
schon ein bisschen zu lahm.
Ich schaff da so 80, im besten Fall 100 Megawatt
pro Sekunde.
Also A, weil das halt langsame Platten sind
und B, weil nur ein Gigabyte Anbindung.
Jetzt kommt hier der Mini-PC,
also meine neue Lösung.
Da stecken tatsächlich 10TB drin
und guckt mal, wie viel weniger Platz das einnimmt.
Hier übrigens zum Vergleich noch ein echtes NAS
mit vier 3,5 Zoll Platten.
Ja, möglich macht's vor allem
eine Entdeckung von mir.
Ich wusste nämlich bis vor kurzem nicht,
dass es SSDs mit 8TB gibt.
Aber hier, von Samsung.
Als dann so langsam die Idee für die
Mini-NAS kam,
war das Teil sogar echt vergleichsweise
günstig.
Das ist aber doch,
von Samsung, da hab ich auch schon mal drauf geguckt,
ist das nicht eine KUVO?
Ja. Und hatten die KUVO-Dinger
nicht das Problem,
dass nach paar hundert MB
die Schreibrate übelst einbricht?
Irgendwas war doch
sass
an den KUVO-Dingern.
Per Firewall-Update,
war diese Sache mit
schreibt sich selbst
irgendwie so schnell kaputt.
Hab ich diesen Samsung
Disk Magic? Ja, hab ich noch drauf.
So grob 300 Euro.
Und leider ist die SSD jetzt auch noch viel teurer geworden.
Das ist auf jeden Fall
teurer als eine Magnetfestplatte,
aber der Unterschied...
Die SSD-Kost ist doppelt von dem Rechner.
Ist zwar da, aber...
Aber so ist es halt.
Also zumindest bei 300 Euro war er das nicht.
Naja. So, und obendrein
ist mir dann beim Ali,
das sagt ein CT-Kollege von mir immer,
und ich hab mir die ersten Male gedacht,
dass das so ein kleines Geschäft ist,
wo er da immer hingeht, wo er den Besitzer kennt,
aber er meint tatsächlich Ali Express,
also den chinesischen Riesenhändler.
Also jedenfalls, beim Ali
hab ich diese Kiste hier entdeckt.
Das ist ein Mini-PC von Topton
mit Intel N11.
Ja, diesen PC gibt's wahrscheinlich
von zehn verschiedenen
Herstellern mit eigenem Logo drauf.
Das ist aber,
die sind China-Sachen oft so.
Gerade wenn du bei Amazon mal guckst,
die haben alle so diese typischen
China-Shop-Namen immer.
Und da kriegst du exakt
die gleiche Hose beispielsweise.
Acht mal.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man hier guckt,
äh,
Outdoor-Hose.
Kurz.
Herren.
Ja, und dann wirst du feststellen,
diese Hose hier,
gibt es von
bestimmt acht verschiedenen Herstellern,
die heißen dann sowas wie
Vesponow,
Hyasospore, Indico,
das sind alles, das sind so,
das sind die typischen China-Chinesen-Shop-Namen.
Also, wenn man das jetzt mal aufmacht,
ich wette mit euch,
das ist ein China-Shop.
Hyasospore.
Erst mal gucken.
Das ist,
das ist ein China-Shop.
Das ist, das ist ein,
ich könnte wetten, das ist ein China-Shop.
Äh, wo kriegen wir das jetzt raus,
ob das ein China-Shop ist,
gescheit?
Contact Us?
Ah, das ist irgendein Dropshipping-Zeug oder so.
Das sind so diese typischen,
diese typischen
China-Ding-Namen auf,
auf Amazon.
Nicht alles, aber
das sieht jetzt, das sieht schon,
das sieht schon wieder so ähnlich aus
als alles. Guckte mal.
Gut, das ist irgendein Shopify-Ding wahrscheinlich.
Also, ihr findet dann
die gleiche Hose hier gefühlt hundert Mal.
Ja, und das ist, das ist bei PC-Hardware
auch so.
Bei AliExpress sitzt man auf jeden Fall deutlich...
Windows 11 ist...
Nein, nicht Windows 11 jetzt.
Sitzt man bei AliExpress deutlich näher an der Quelle.
...100 CPU und die ist
in Homeserver-Kreisen gerade ziemlich
angesagt, weil das Teil nur eine TDP
von 6 Watt hat.
Nicht, dass der ganze Rechner nur 6 Watt
zieht, aber es ist halt auf jeden Fall
deutlich weniger als andere
CPUs, vor allem, weil der N100...
Aber guck mal, es ist genau das, was ich getippt
habe, was drauf ist.
Embedded Intel
J4, irgendetwas.
Dafür echt Leistung.
Davon hatte ich auch schon ein Board, oder ich
hab sogar noch hier welche liegen.
Sogar noch mehr als zwei Boards davon
liegen, aber nur Boards, ohne Rechner
drum rum. Das ist
eine wirklich coole Plattform.
Ja, und dieser Top-Ton
Mini-PC hat drei Eigenschaften,
die ich für meinen Homeserver
sehr, sehr gerne hätte. Also keine Lüfter,
komplett passiv gekühlt, das
Alu-Gehäuse hat hier oben so Kühlrippen,
neben einer M2-SSD
auch noch Platz für einen
2,5 Zoll SATA-Datenträger.
Also hier kann ich die gerade erwähnte
8 PB Samsung
...
... SSD einbauen.
Und last but not least 2,5
GB Ethernet-Anschluss.
Beziehungsweise sogar direkt vier Stück
davon. Konkret sind das
Intel i226V.
Ihr könnt euch damit also auch nut...
Solange es Intel-Netzwerkkarten sind, ist es immer nice.
Intel-Netzwerkkarten werden unter Linux
immer super unterstützt.
... oder eine Firewall bauen. Obendrein hat das Ding
auch noch angenehm viele USB-Buchsen,
nämlich vier USB 2.0 und
zwei USB 3.0-Anschlüsse.
Und tatsächlich auch sogar Slots für SIM-Karten.
Also wenn man sein Internet
... Moment.
5G und 5G
haben die unterschiedliche
SIM-Karten-Formate,
5G, Keck, Alu.
... Mobilfunk bezieht.
Die habe ich aber nicht ausprobiert.
Den Top-Ton-Mini-PC gibt es auch
vorbestückt mit M2, SSDs und RAM.
Ich habe den aber als
Barebone bestellt, also nur mit
CPU. Ich rechne euch hier mal die Kosten
für dieses System, was ich in diesem Video
benutze, vor. Also 159 Euro
habe ich für den Mini-PC mit
Intel N100 bezahlt.
159 Euro für einen 16 GB DDR5
RAM-Riegel, also
SO-DIMM ist das.
125 Euro für eine 2 TB M2
SSD. Genau genommen habe ich es nicht
bezahlt, sondern ich habe eine M2
von Teracle genommen, die in der
Redaktion halt rumlag. Und
Den Hersteller habe ich noch nie gehört.
Kennt ihr den Hersteller? Teracle?
550 Euro
für die 8 TB
SATA-SSD
von Samsung. Ja, finde ich
auch teuer, aber man kann die 8 TB
SSD auch weglassen oder halt
eine kleinere einbauen. Mir ging es ja in
diesem Video vor allem darum zu zeigen, dass
so ein unsichtbares NAS möglich ist.
Und ein NAS mit weniger als 10 TB
fand ich irgendwie lame.
Und ja, deshalb beißen wir da mal in den
sauren Preisapfel. Also
884 Euro
kostet das ganze System, wenn ihr das nachkaufen
wollt. Teuer, aber auch geil.
Sehen wir gleich. Ich wollte nur kurz nochmal
betonen, wenn ihr die 8 TB nicht
Also performance-technisch
ist das Ding auf jeden Fall
brauchbar dafür.
Ich habe ja mehr oder weniger das gleiche
CPU, gleiches, also nicht
gleiches Board, aber gleiche CPU auf anderem
Board mal benutzt.
Ist okay, weil
Intel glücklicherweise
bei
dieser Board-Generation, beziehungsweise
halt auch bei dieser CPU-Generation, das ist ja
Embedded, da wird ja keine CPU draufgestöpselt,
die ist ja quasi draufgelötet im Endeffekt.
Gibt es ja nur Board und CPU in einem.
Glücklicherweise dort schon ihre
Krypto-Extensions drauf hat.
Ohne Krypto-Extensions wäre das Ding
eine schlechte NAS-Plattform.
Dank Krypto-Extensions in der CPU
finde ich, ist es eine ziemlich gute NAS-Plattform.
Da kannst du nämlich deine Festplatte auch
voll verschlüsseln und
du hast kaum Leistungseinbußen.
Weil du halt nicht
Ver- und
Entschlüsselung beim Schreiben über das Netzwerk
nebenbei von der CPU machen
musst, wobei mit Krypto-Extensions
macht sie CPU auch, aber
verursacht keine normale.
Nicht so hohe normale CPU-Last.
Und dann kriegst du dann auch deine
2,5 Gig
Saturated.
Was mich jetzt noch interessieren würde ist,
ob es ein Dual-Core oder ein
Quad-Core ist.
Dual-Core wäre mir
etwas zu lahm.
Raid finde ich auch unsinnig, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich weiß, anscheinend haben sich ja wohl Leute
drüber aufgeregt.
Wir müssen uns gleich über die Kommentare heran gucken.
Ich finde das eigentlich sinnig
in der Kombination
es ohne Raid zu machen.
Es ist eh kein Platz mehr für
eine zweite Festplatte drinnen.
Und nachdem
im Heimbereich
ein Backup aus meiner Sicht viel viel
sinnvoller ist als ein Raid 1
steht das bei dieser Kiste
ja keinem im Wege.
Weil der Unterschied, also der
grundsätzliche Unterschied dazwischen ist ja
Raid 1 ist für Ausfallsicherheit
Backup ist
für sagen wir mal
Ratesicherheit, falls man das so nennen kann.
Weil ein Raid 1
schützt dich nicht gegen
fehlerhafte Bedienung.
Also sagen wir mal du gehst jetzt auf die Kiste drauf
und sagst rm-rf keckel
danach ist
keckel weg.
Auf beiden Platten, weil es ist ein Raid 1
es ist gespiegelt.
Wenn du ein Backup hast, so asynchron einmal in der Nacht
kannst du die Datei löschen
aber
im Backup ist er noch da.
Und nachdem die Ausfallraten
von solchen SSDs
ziemlich gering sind, dass du nicht
damit rechnen musst, dass dir alle paar Wochen da die SSD
abkackt, das wäre ein ganz schön teures Vergnügen auch
ist das ok.
Dann bestellst du dir
eine neue SSD, baust sie ein
und kopierst die Sachen aus dem Backup wieder drauf.
Fertig. Da hast du
vielleicht mal einen Tag Ausfall bis Amazon kommt
oder wenn du in ein Geschäft fährst
noch weniger. Kannst ja auch theoretisch noch
eine 8 TB baugleiche
SSD daneben legen, wenn du das
ganz schnell haben willst. Baust du das
aus, baust die neue SSD ein,
kopierst die Sachen vom Backup drauf und bist wieder da.
Also
ich sehe jetzt nicht so sehr
wo es das
RAID 1 im Heimbereich jetzt
wirklich groß rausreißen würde.
Es ist nice to have
das gebe ich zu, plus ein externes Backup
wenn überhaupt dann immer
dazu.
Also erst ein Backup und dann
RAID 1 und nicht umgedreht. Aber
auch
statistisch gesehen wird
es jetzt einem nicht so viel
ersparen. Genau das ist
ein sehr schönes Beispiel Chatge.
Das ist ein sehr schönes Beispiel. Irgendwelche
Verschlüsselung, Ransomware, Shit
am Start und
es ist alles verschlüsselt, egal ob
RAID oder nicht. Klar gibt es jetzt
natürlich noch so ein paar Zwischendinger. Könnte
beispielsweise auch sagen, man macht einen
ZFS RAID
mit regelmäßigen Snapshots.
Wobei die
Snapshots auch Speicherplatz belegen.
Also irgendwo muss es hin.
Dann hättest du beides ein bisschen kombiniert, aber es ist
ja vom Ansatz her
das gleiche. Du hast einmal
eine Spiegelung
für die Ausfallsicherheit und einmal
Snapshots bzw. ein Backup
für hups, ich habe aus versehen was gelöscht
oder es wurde was verschlüsselt und so.
So weiter.
Brauchen solltet ihr euch 2 TB reichen, dann kostet
euch das System 334 Euro.
Hört sich ja schon mal nicht so schlimm an.
Okay, der Zusammenbau erstmal.
Wird ja auch eine positive Überraschung.
Die Ali-Lieferung hat weniger als eine
Woche gedauert und das Ding
Das kommt wahrscheinlich entweder
aus einem EU-Warenlager
also sprich
Spanien, Niederlande, Frankreich oder so.
Wir können doch gerade mal gucken.
Ich will mir das nicht kaufen, aber
wir können es ja mal
angucken. Oder es
kommt direkt mit dem Flugzeug.
Wobei da hatte ich ja auch
letzten Spaß mit dem Thema Flugzeug.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich euch
das schon mal erzählt habe.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich es in der App noch sehe.
Falls ich euch das schon
erzählt habe, dann sagt mir
Recycled Story.
Aber
ich habe mir letztens aus China
was bestellt.
Puzzlemeister, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich habe mir letztens aus China was bestellt.
Ich habe mir eine Custom Platine
PCB anfertigen lassen.
Und
passt mal auf, was das Ding für
merkwürdige
Wege genommen hat.
Also, äh
wo ist es denn?
Moment, äh
Moment, wo habe ich es denn?
J L C
P C B
Kann das sein, dass sie das nur per E-Mail geschickt haben?
Oder so?
Hier ist es.
Okay, also.
Shipment, Shipment Updates.
Also, es ging los.
In
China. Und zwar
China People's Republic
Shuangxiang
Delta Area.
So.
Dann ging es weiter dort.
Irgendwann kam es in Hongkong raus.
Und dann ging es von Hongkong
ins Flugzeug.
Dann
ist es dort irgendwie durch das Clearing
Clearance. Dann kam es in Leipzig
raus. So. Dann kam es in Leipzig
raus. Leipzig und
Seoul. Und DHL habe ich ja schon
öfters mal
negative Erfahrungen
gemacht. Gerade mit Bestellungen aus den USA.
So, Leipzig. Okay, dann ist es in Leipzig.
Und dann liegt es
einfach einen Tag in Leipzig rum.
Und dann denkst du dir so, ja, was macht es denn in Leipzig?
Jo man, man weiß es nicht. Dann kommt
irgendwann eine Nachricht. Ah ja, okay.
Es ist Recycle Story. Ich habe es schon
erzählt. Egal. In der Kürze.
Dann liegt es einen Tag in Leipzig rum und steht auf einmal da
Shipment is on hold.
So. Und dann ein Tag
später gucke ich in die
Sendeverfolgung. Oh, das ist
aber gut hier. Haben sie sich übertroffen.
Bei mir hat es nicht geklappt. So.
Dann gucke ich, also das war
noch im April. Dann gucke ich in die
Sendeverfolgung. Es war schon in Leipzig
wohlgemerkt. Das war von China nach Leipzig.
So. Und dann gucke ich nach.
Nächster Eintrag.
Es ist in Kanada.
In Quebec. Oder wie auch immer
man das ausspricht.
Quebec, Kanada. Also es ist
von China nach Leipzig.
Wo es dann hätte nach Frankfurt gemusst.
Es ist nach Kanada.
Von Kanada.
Quebec.
Quebec. Wie auch immer.
Danach ist es von Kanada
nach
Ich habe auch schon wieder vergessen wie es heißt.
Kinikinati.
USA, Ohio.
Danach ist es East Midlands
UK.
Und dann ist es wieder. Haltet euch fest.
Danach ist es wieder in Leipzig.
Eingetroffen.
Und dann ging es
von Leipzig
nach Frankfurt. Und dann kam es bei mir
an.
Das Paket ist legit
einmal um die Welt.
Ihr müsst euch überlegen. Das ist von China
nach Leipzig.
Nach Nordamerika.
Nach UK. Nach Deutschland.
Das ist einmal
ein super effizienter Transport.
Das ist einmal gratis
um die Welt nochmal zusätzlich.
Genau.
Da wusste jeder Geheimdienst noch schnell eine Wand zu einbauen.
Die Engländer
haben dann zum Schluss gesagt. Ey ich will auch noch.
Versand.
Versand. War glaube ich sogar.
Ne. Versand war nicht kostenlos.
Bei JLC, PCB.
Aber es war billig.
Es war auf jeden Fall billig.
Und ich habe im Endeffekt 20 Euro bezahlt.
In Afrika war es nicht.
Es liegt aber auch nicht so irgendwie auf dem Weg.
Gut.
In China auch nicht.
Wobei Kanada würde auf dem Weg liegen wenn man andersrum fliegt.
Wie lange hat es gedauert?
Ja es war leider 1. Mai Feiertag noch dazwischen.
Es kam am 3. Mai.
Am 3. Mai.
Und losgeschickt wurde es am
Gucken wir mal
wenn es in den Flieger gegangen ist.
28. April.
Ohne Feiertag dazwischen wäre es schneller da gewesen.
Ich habe es
extra so bestellt, dass es noch vor dem Feiertag ankommt.
Aber DHL hat sich ja gedacht.
Max du kriegst es nicht.
Es muss einmal quer über die halbe Welt geschickt werden.
Ja gut.
Whatever.
Zumindest war es billig.
20 Euro habe ich bezahlt.
Für 5 Boards.
5 Custom PCBs.
Und die PCBs sehen folgendermaßen aus.
Ah.
Ja.
So sehen die zum Beispiel aus.
Schönes Vorschaubild.
Nice Fivehead Archive.
So sehen die PCBs aus.
So kamen die 1 zu 1 aus China an.
Also nicht mit dem Widerstand oben drauf.
Also nur dieses Board hier.
Und ich habe jetzt
eine nice neue Kamera für solche Streams.
Sehr nice.
Guck mal.
Wie das jetzt ausschaut.
Ja guck hier.
Hier sieht man es.
Die Boards habe ich bestellt.
Die Platinen habe ich bestellt in China.
Also wirklich.
Wie günstig das ist.
Wie schnell es insgesamt funktioniert hat.
Und wie ordentlich die Dinger
doch dann auch gefertigt sind.
Für 20 Euro.
Kann sich nicht beschweren.
5 Stück habe ich davon bestellt.
Hätte ich mehr bestellt.
Wäre es sogar anteilmäßig noch
deutlich günstiger geworden.
Das läuft.
Oh.
Das läuft auf einem eigenen Server von
Sibaro.
Die bei sich.
Fragt mich nicht.
Die haben da ganz abgedrehtes Zeug.
Die haben einen AS.
Ein eigenes IPv6 AS.
Also BGP.
Internet Routing Gedöns.
Worüber wir jetzt
per Cloudflare IPv4
Traffic tunneln.
Hast du das Board
schon in die Klimaanlage eingebaut?
Ne.
Ich habe ein Video gesehen wie das funktioniert.
Und leider muss man die Klimaanlage dafür
mehr auseinander bauen.
Ich weiß nicht ob ich da Bock drauf habe.
Zur Zeit.
Ich habe da noch nichts gemacht.
Ok.
Jetzt gucken wir das Video mal fertig.
Was wollte ich nochmal gucken?
Warum habe ich die Seite nochmal aufgemacht?
Achso von wo das losgeschickt wird.
Ok.
Voraussichtliche Lieferung.
Also wahrscheinlich kommt das wirklich aus China.
Wenn ihr das hier hinschreibt.
Normalerweise kann man den Versand hier auswählen.
Nur wenn man
eingeloggt ist.
Da gibt es ja verschiedene Versandvarianten.
Oftmals bei AliExpress.
Und
das kann man wahrscheinlich nur auswählen.
Wenn man eingeloggt ist.
Ist immer ein bisschen weird bei AliExpress.
Garantierte Lieferung.
Das ist aber sehr nett.
Dass ich etwas kaufe und es dann auch bekomme.
Also
je nachdem was man da auswählen kann.
Ach hier.
Ohne Mist.
Es ist jedes mal
ein anderer
Ok AliExpress Standard Shipping.
Jedes mal ein mir bis jetzt
noch nicht bekannter
chinesischer Versanddienstleister.
Ich habe da bestimmt schon keine Ahnung
16 verschiedene oder so gehabt.
Die haben unendlich viele.
Welche Zahlungsoptionen?
Meistens Paypal wenn Paypal möglich ist.
Ich habe auch einen Alipay Account.
Den musste ich mal irgendwann machen.
Vor zig Jahren als man dort noch
tatsächlich per Alipay bezahlt hat.
Das ging dann so.
Du hast Alipay hat Paypal
Du hast Alipay mit Paypal verbunden.
Und dann hast du auf AliExpress mit Alipay bezahlt.
Guck mal DHL.
25 Euro Versand.
10. Juni AliExpress Standard Versand.
Umsonst.
Das ist so heftig subventioniert.
Teilweise.
Aber nicht mein Problem.
Na gut. Gucken wir jetzt das Video fertig.
Machte dann auch wirklich einen sehr robusten Eindruck.
Mit diesem voll Alu Gehäuse.
Und der Zusammenbau war tatsächlich auch extrem easy.
RAM Riegel reinklicken.
M2 reinklicken.
Und festschrauben.
2,5 Zoll SATA SSD an den Deckel schrauben.
Das mitgelieferte SATA Kabel anschließen.
Und das Gehäuse zuschrauben.
Also das schwierigste war eigentlich auszuprobieren
wie man das SATA Kabel drehen muss.
Damit der Deckel zugeht.
Aber ja 30 Sekunden Sache.
So und jetzt aber zur Performance.
Also erstmal anschalten.
Und falls ihr euch jetzt fragt.
Ob das mit dem Geboote und dem Datenträger auswählen
alles easy geklappt hat.
Oder ob ich da erst Chinesisch für lernen musste.
Ne das ist ein ganz normales
Ami BIOS auf Englisch.
Mit vielen Einstellungsmöglichkeiten.
Und alles sehr normal.
Also wenn ihr schon mal ein normales Mainboard bedient habt.
Da fällt hier jetzt nichts außergewöhnliches auf.
Auch das Auswählen des Boot Datenträgers
überhaupt kein Problem.
Ich hab dann erstmal meine USB SSD
Ami BIOS gekaut.
Das ist so eine Linux Distribution.
Nur für Spiele Emulation.
Da hatten wir schon mal ein Video zu gemacht.
Und ja das Ding ballert.
Also sogar die am schwierigsten zu emulierenden PS2 Spiele
wie God of War 2.
Das klappt auf Anhieb.
Und recht flüssig.
Andere PS2 Spiele laufen sogar in doppelter
als der Originalauflösung mit stabilen 60 FPS.
Ja und natürlich sind auch Dreamcast
N64...
Ja wobei ich so ein Ding halt echt nicht dafür kaufen würde.
MQB und Wii U
bei vielen Spielen noch kein Problem. Aber kannst ja mal ausprobieren.
Zum Teil ist die Performance bei dem Teil
nochmal deutlich besser als bei einem
Raspberry Pi 5.
Ja und das wird auch unter Windows 11 deutlich.
Das hab ich nämlich danach auch mal testweise
installiert und den Benchmark
Geekbench 6 laufen lassen.
Da schafft der Mini PC 3017
Multicore Punkte.
Mehr als das Doppelte als der Raspberry Pi 5.
Ja und hier noch das Resultat von
3DMark Timespy.
Die Schwupptizität von Windows 11 war auch
wirklich gut. Das fühlte sich alles super an.
Was mich dann erstmal fast...
Das Ding halt auch nicht dafür.
War gespannt wann endlich die NAS-Geschichte kommt.
...umgehauen hat war, als ich mit Steam Cyberpunk 2077
installieren wollte.
86 GB sollten dafür heruntergeladen werden.
Und dann sagte Steam
irgendwas von 5 Minuten Ladedauer.
Und ich so was? Hä?
Ich hab doch nur eine Internetleitung mit einem Gigabit.
Wieso steht da was von 2,1 Gigabit?
Hat der Ali-Rechner jetzt meine
Leitung direkt neu gemacht?
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Zieht das von einem anderen
Rechner im Netzwerk oder was?
Steam holt sich die Daten nicht aus dem Internet,
sondern von meinem Gaming-Budget aus dem lokalen Netz.
Das steht da auch, wenn ich hingeguckt hätte.
Okay, habe ich zuerst nicht gecheckt.
Aber auf jeden Fall, das 2,5 Gigabit
Ethernet hat sich schon mal gelohnt.
Das bringt wirklich was.
Kleiner Einschub hier. Es müssen natürlich alle
genutzten Geräte 2,5 Gigabit
unterstützen. Bei mir ist das so, dass meine
Fritzbox 6690
nur einen einzelnen 2,5 Gigabit
Anschluss hat. Deshalb habe ich mir noch
diesen Fünffach-Switch mit 2,5
Gigabit Unterstützung gekauft. Ja und
damit konnte ich dann den Mini-PC
nass und meinen Hauptrechner
anschließen. Also schön schnell
Daten übertragen, das geht schon mal. Nice.
Aber das ist dann irgendwann
hart eingebrochen bei der Cyberpunk
Installation. Ich habe dann mal die
Temperatursensoren ausgelesen mit
hwinfo. Und ja, die M2 SSD,
die schien mir der Übeltäter zu sein.
Da zeigte nämlich der Sensor am
SSD-Controller heftige
104 Grad an und der Hauptsensor
der SSD auch noch eher
unangenehme 82 Grad.
Ja, ich vermute, das war so viel,
dass die SSD in so einen deutlich
langsameren Modus geschaltet ist. Und
das Problem tauchte übrigens auch beim Installieren
sehr vieler Windows-Updates auf. Also
auf einmal fühlte sich das System
gar nicht mehr so schwuppig an und
überall hakte und
lahmte das. Ja, aber da ich
den Mini-PC aber ja als Home-Server unter
Linux, also konkret mit Unraid...
Ja, dass das passiv gekühlt war,
voller Pulle, dass das nicht lange
mitmacht, ist klar. Das könntest
du eventuell auch bei
längeren Datenübertragungen
haben, aber nachdem das den Crypto-Extensions
hat, sollte noch nicht mal groß
die Verschlüsselung bzw.
Entschlüsselung, je nachdem ob du drauf kopierst oder runter
kopierst, da die CPU
so an die Grenze bringen,
dass es überhitzt.
Wobei es halt sich nur runtertaktet.
Das kackt ja nicht ab.
Ja, bei solchen passiv gekühlten
Dingern ist das halt oftmals so.
Wie gesagt, das ist beim Raspberry Pi ähnlich.
Mein Lieblings...
Mein Lieblings Raspberry Pi Case
ist ja das hier. Gibt es schon mehrere
Generationen von. Weil das
ein großer passiv gekühlter
Alu-Block ist. Du machst so ein Ding hier
dann auf die CPU
und...
Wobei ich mir beim Raspberry Pi immer nicht merken kann,
was GPU und was CPU ist.
Das da wahrscheinlich.
Und das ist dann auch so, wenn du das Ding
laufen lässt, für
20 Minuten volle Pulle,
dann wird das auch ziemlich warm.
Selbst wenn du das Gehäuse anfasst, ist es unangenehm
mit der Hand anzugreifen.
Was man natürlich sicherlich machen
kann ist, wenn man...
Wenn ich mir dieses Gehäuse hier so angucke,
dann hat es ja so ein paar Fake
Kühlrippen. Also wenn man
das Gehäuse wo
stehen hat, wo ein bisschen Luftfluss
drum rum ist, dann könnte ich mir
vorstellen,
dass das durchaus
einiges bringt.
...laufen lassen wollte,
bin ich nicht ins Windows Troubleshooting
eingestiegen. Und ich wollte zuerst mal wissen,
ob das vielleicht unter Linux gar nicht erst
passiert. Was ich aber vorher noch gemacht habe,
ich habe so ein billiges Heatsink für
5 Euro auf die M2
draufgeschnallt. Also, wie
läuft das Ding als Server? Also erstmal
das Unraid-Image auf dem Stick und los.
Der Heatsink wird ja auch nicht
viel bringen ohne Luftfluss da drinnen.
Das sorgt vielleicht dafür, dass es ein bisschen länger
braucht, bis es heiß wird.
Wieder beeindruckend,
wie schnell und unproblematisch
Unraid funktioniert. Und nein,
ich werde nicht dafür bezahlt.
Und ja, mich regt das neue Preismodell
von Unraid auch total auf.
Also, auf jeden Fall hatte ich nach 2 Minuten
eine funktionierende
SMB-Freigabe.
Ich habe dann einen Ordner so eingestellt,
dass der ausschließlich diese
heißlaufende M2-SSD verwendet.
Und nicht die kühlere SATA-SSD.
Und da habe ich dann ungefähr
einen Terabyte übers Netzwerk
draufgeschrieben. Übrigens mit konstanten
280 Megabyte pro Sekunde.
Also dreimal so schnell, wie auf meinem
alten Home-Server mit Gigabit-Anschluss.
Das hat mich also schon mal gefreut.
Und die 280 Megabyte pro Sekunde
werden übrigens auch auf der 8 Terabyte
SATA-SSD übers Netz erreicht.
So, aber ich wollte ja gucken, ob die M2
überhitzt. Ich habe dann gleichzeitig
alle CPU-Kerne voll ausgelastet.
Indem ich auf dem Home-Server so einen
lokalen KI-Chatbot installiert
habe. Also als Docker-Container.
Harter Stresstest. Und das
auch noch bei unge... Ich hätte ehrlich
gesagt einfach Stress gestartet.
Das ist so ein Kommandozeilen-
Tool zum CPU-Auslastung
generieren unter Linux.
Übrigens, sehr gut auch in Kombination
mit STUI.
Wer keinen Bock hat, Stress-Argumente
von Hand
einzustellen, der kann
STUI starten. Geht hier einfach auf Stress
und jetzt BÄM!
CPU-Auslastung 100%.
Was ihr auch mit Hardtop seht. So, guck hier. BÄM!
Volle Pulle. Ne, der Stream ist
nicht F. Das ist in meiner VM und die hat nicht genug
CPUs, dass der Stream F ist.
Man kann hier natürlich auch noch einstellen, was man
machen will, wie viele Work-Accounts und so, whatever.
Aber für einfach mal,
aber für einfach mal kurz
die Kiste auslasten,
dürfte das die einfachste Variante unter Linux
sein. Stress in den STUI installieren.
Hier anklicken.
Also einfach mal Enter drücken an der Stelle.
Kannst hier, kannst umschalten inzwischen. Nur gucken, wieviel ist.
Und die ganze Auslastung verursacht. BÄM!
Und man kann jetzt natürlich
auch sagen, ey, ich will ein Summary und
wir machen plus 4 zum Beispiel.
Oh, und dann gehen wir hier auf Stress und dann
Ups.
Habe ich nicht gespeichert.
Zwei.
Ich bin zu unfähig dafür, das zu
bedienen. Was auch immer.
100% CPU-Auslast.
Welcher Terminal-Emulator ist das?
Das Terminal hier. Das ist Westterm.
Westterm.
Und das wichtigste,
das wichtigste
Feature an Westterm ist,
es kann Bilder und Gifs
auf der Kommandozeile anzeigen.
Das heißt, man kann jetzt
eine Endlosschleife-Ajajagifs machen.
Enorm wichtig.
Das ist das
Killer-Feature schlechthin.
Und wenn man dann
Abbrechen drückt, dann
ist die Animation
geht trotzdem weiter.
Gekauft. Ja, finde ich auch.
Das ist das wichtigste Feature
überhaupt.
Rest kann man vergessen, aber
das zählt das Terminal.
Umgebungstemperatur. Und das Resultat
der Haupttemperatursensor auf
der M2 hat maximal
79 Grad gezeigt. Der
Controllersensor auf der M2 blieb bei
unter 90 Grad. Und es waren
keine relevanten Einbrüche
bei den Transferraten zu sehen.
Wenn die CPU-Auslastung hochging,
dann ging die Transferrat... Können das andere Konsolen nicht?
Nö. Die wenigsten können das.
Mir fällt eigentlich nichts ein,
was das noch in dieser
guten Integration kann.
Es gibt noch
KITI, das kann das. Aber KITI
hat andere Probleme, KITI. Der KITI-Autor
ist ja der Meinung, niemand verwendet
TMUX über SSH und solche komischen
Dinger. Ja.
Ansonsten fällt mir nichts mehr ein, was
es noch kann.
... hat er ungefähr auf
260, 270, aber trotzdem
völlig okay und völlig nice.
Das einzige Problem, das geholfen...
Sirius Max, kennst du den? Hast du
dir schon mal ein paar Sachen von ihm durchgelesen, ja?
Dem
KITI-Programmierer?
Ja, der ist ein bisschen merkwürdig.
Das ist richtig viel
Pega, ja.
... wurde so heiß, dass ich das
ohne Schmerzen nicht länger als ein paar Sekunden
anfassen konnte. Gemessen habe ich
auf der Oberfläche über 50 Grad
und das ist tatsächlich oberhalb
der in der EU... Wisst ihr Leute, da hätten wir jetzt
wunderbar, hätten wir das hier gemacht,
hätten wir jetzt wunderbar unseren selbst
entwickelten ZigBee
Temperatursensor verwenden können für
Maschinenrichtlinie
festgelegten Verbrennungsschwelle
bei einer Minute Kontaktdauer.
Bei 10 Minuten sind das
sogar nur 48 Grad.
Also, das muss ich sagen, das finde ich unschön.
Ich fasse das aber natürlich normalerweise
nicht an, das Ding, aber ich habe trotzdem...
Aber es steht vielleicht auf einem Holz drauf.
... Hitze und Elektronik
nicht so gut. Naja, aber zumindest
wenn der Homeserver gerade nichts macht, kühlt
sich das Gehäuse auch wieder ab. Also
ist es immer noch warm, aber dieses
heftige Aufheizen passiert wirklich nur beim
Kopieren von großen Datenmengen.
Was ja nicht so häufig passiert.
So, jetzt wird es auch nochmal erfreulich.
Der selbstgebastelte Homeserver zieht
im Leerlauf mit Unraid weniger
als 11 Watt aus der Steckdose.
Und Leerlauf.
Das hatte ich mehr oder weniger mit...
Ich hatte ja hier ein sehr ähnliches
Board, hatte ich das auch, war unter 10 Watt.
Gerade wenn man mit PowerTop
noch ein paar Sachen einschaltet,
dann bist du deutlich unter 10
Watt idle. Das ist ein
sehr nicer Wert.
Irgendwie Ruhezustand oder so.
Das heißt, das Ding ist sofort da, wenn man es
ausreicht von außen. Wenn ich was draufkopiere
und gleichzeitig die CPU auslasse,
dann steigt die Leistungsaufnahme
auf maximal 28 Watt.
Also maximal.
Und das ist weniger als viele
konventionelle Nasse im
Leerlauf aufnehmen. Und übrigens die
11 Watt Leerlaufleistung sind auch weniger
als mein viel langsamerer, bisheriger
Homeserver. Na gut, allein schon wegen dem Zeug.
Mit 4 USB-Platten.
Der nimmt im Ruhezustand ungefähr 12 Watt.
Und da müssen die Platten dann auch erst
zwölffachen, also wenn man sie verwenden will,
was ein paar Sekunden dauert.
Das ist bei dem N100 Mini-Homeserver
Aber 8 vs. 12 ist ja
im Prinzip nichts.
SSD ist nicht der Fall.
Ja und generell muss ich sagen, merkt man auch
in Euro pro Jahr oder so,
keine Ahnung, ich kann das schlecht schätzen.
Immer wieder, dass das Ding schneller ist als
mein alter Server. Also zum Beispiel schon bei der
Unraid-Oberfläche, das geht auf jeden Fall zackiger.
Okay, das ist ziemlich unwichtig, aber man merkt
das definitiv auch bei dem
lokalen Netflix-Plex.
Ach ja, was ich gucken wollte, war das jetzt eigentlich ein Quad-Core oder nicht?
Hups, was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
War das jetzt ein Quad-Core oder nicht?
Ich denke mal, ich denke mal schon.
Ja, die Rechner sind enorm energieeffizient
geworden, was Idle angeht, ja.
Äh...
Ist das ein Quad-Core?
Ja, ist es.
Nice. Excellent.
Jetzt muss ich mal kurz gucken, wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Mal, was ich gerne
benutze, wenn man da ein Video
der nimmt im Ruhezustand, um
ein Video zu machen, dann ist das
der
2,5 Gigabit wahrscheinlich eher das Limitierende sind oder gut, 2,5 Gigabit heißt, man kann maximal theoretisch, lass mal überlegen, 125 sind es bei Gigabit, 250 sind es bei 2 Gigabit und dann nochmal die Hälfte obendrauf.
Also sagen wir nochmal so 60, so 310 oder so, irgendwie, also 310 MB, Megabyte die Sekunde, wären bei 2,5 Gigabit jetzt so mal aus dem Kopf so über den Daumen gepeilt, ungefähr maximal möglich.
Ja, dann beschränkt vielleicht die SSD doch ein bisschen, ich weiß nicht, was die KUVO schafft, wirklich lange Zeit kontinuierlich zu übertragen, mag sein, aber die KUVO ist die einzige, die es gibt in 8 Terabyte.
Also ich bilde mir ein, dass die KUVO einbricht nach einer Weile, nach so 1, 2 Minuten volle Pulle auf, ja, was weiß ich, 250, 300 MB, muss man sich jetzt Benchmarks angucken, weiß ich aus dem Kopf auch nicht.
Zumindest ist das wahrscheinlich echt ein ganz guter Match für die Interface-Geschwindigkeit, dürfte ungefähr, also dürfte nichts das andere großartig ausbremsen.
Zugespielt werden, also richtig cool.
Und generell kann man mit dem N100 wirklich coole Sachen machen, von dem lokalen KI-Chatbot, habe ich ja schon erzählt, aber ich habe zum Beispiel auch mal Windows als Docker-Container in Unraid installiert und da dann über den Browser VNC Remote Desktop mäßig drauf zugegriffen.
Das ist auch tatsächlich mehr als ein Gag, also wenn man zum Beispiel nur Linux oder macOS benutzt und nur unregelmäßig irgendwie eine spezielle Software kurz unter Windows verwenden will, dann kann man das über so ein Docker-Windows auf dem Home-Server auf jeden Fall machen.
Mein Fakt.
Das ist ja eigentlich nicht wirklich.
Ich gehe ganz stark davon aus, dass ihm das auch klar ist und das einfach nur so im Video erwähnt wird, aufgrund der, um das simpler darzustellen, das ist ja gar kein Docker-Windows, das ist ja gar kein richtiges Windows, was im Docker läuft.
Das ist ein KVM, was quasi, das ist ein Docker-Image, was ein fertiges Windows-Image mitliefert, was dann in KVM durch, was dann in KVM...
...gestartet wird, was du durchreichen musst an Docker.
Also letztendlich ist es eine KVM, die da gestartet wird, über dieses Docker-Image.
Es ist Docker, in das du dein lokales KVM passt, also Dev-KVM und im Endeffekt bringt dieses Docker-Image halt nur die Sachen mit, die du brauchst, um Windows laufen lassen zu können.
Also irgendein Windows-ISO, was bootbar ist.
Bringt das mit und dann startet es einfach eine KVM-VM, so wie wenn du es selbst in KVM installiert hättest.
Also der Docker-Part macht es eigentlich nur einen Ticken einfacher und dass du nicht selbst klicken musst.
KVM ist nicht QEMO, KVM ist KVM, das ist das, was im Linux-Kernel drin ist.
QEMO ist ein, keine Ahnung, Emulator-Projekt, was noch mehrere Plattformen...
...emulieren kann, zum Beispiel kannst du mit QEMO auch ARM auf x86, x64 emulieren.
Was KVM von QEMO benutzt, sind ein paar Bestandteile, aber nicht die eigentliche Virtualisierung unter x86.
Es benutzt beispielsweise das BIOS, glaube ich zumindest.
Also die QEMO-BIOS-Geschichten, das benutzt glaube ich die QEMO SATA-Treiber und solche Geschichten benutzen die.
Aber KVM selbst benutzt die Linux-Virtualisierung, die Linux-x86-Virtualisierung, nicht die QEMO-Virtualisierung.
Wir benutzen nur ein paar Teile von QEMO.
Nee, das sagt er einfach aufgrund, dass das Video nicht den Fokus hat da drauf.
Als CT-Redakteur weißt du sicherlich, dass es eine KVM ist im Docker.
Warum sollte man das mehr thematisieren als notwendig für das Video?
Also generell...
...ist dieser Home-Server schon echt ziemlich nice.
Ein paar Sachen haben mich auch überrascht, also zum Beispiel, dass man tatsächlich sogar bei der Bedienung von Plex einen Unterschied merkt zum alten Server.
Und wie viel die SSDs bringen und der 2,5 Gigabit Anschluss.
Etwas wenig vertrauenserweckend ist allerdings diese Hitzigkeit.
Also ich habe beim Einsatz als Home-Server an mehreren Tagen Dauerbetrieb keine Probleme festgestellt.
Waren erstmal Abfälle bis Sommer ist.
Wenn dann in der Bude die Umgebung...
die Umgebungstemperatur
28 Grad ist.
Also ich merke das bei mir auch immer.
Ich habe bei mir in meinem kleinen
Serverabteil hier, ich habe da
keine Klimaanlage und nichts drin.
Und die
Geräuschkulisse ist im Sommer
bei
höherer Außentemperatur da drin etwas
höher als im Winter.
Die Lüfter drehen halt irgendwie so 20% höher.
Einfach weil die Umgebungstemperatur wärmt.
Es ist nicht irgendwie in problematischen
Sphären, ja, aber
man merkt es anhand des Geräusches,
dass das was ausmacht.
Ich bin mir halt unsicher, ob das auch im Sommer
gut geht, wenn die Umgebungstemperatur...
Ja, siehste? Siehste?
Genau die gleiche. Leute, ich schwöre,
ich habe das Video vorher nicht geguckt.
War genau mein Gedanke gerade.
Also vielleicht
würde ich die M2
wieder ausbauen und dann nur die
SATA SSD nutzen. 8 TB
reichen ja auch erstmal.
Ich gucke mir das nochmal ein bisschen an.
Ich glaube, es ist kein Problem, ehrlich gesagt.
Die Dinger verkraften
alle ganz gut, die Hitze.
Und
es bleibt,
wenn man da jetzt nicht eine halbe
Stunde volle Pulle und nebenbei was...
Ich glaube, es bleibt im erträglichen Rahmen.
Ich denke, das ist ganz okay. Wahrscheinlich dürfte
die einfachste Abhilfe sein, wenn es da wirklich
Probleme gibt, das Gehäuse
irgendwie einem leichten
Airflow auszusetzen.
USB-Lüfter da vorstellen oder so.
Einen Disclaimer würde ich auch
gerne noch loswerden. Wenn ihr Hardware,
von AliExpress bestellt,
habt ihr natürlich einige Nachteile gegenüber
dem Kauf bei europäischen Händlern.
Also A gilt natürlich der europäische
Verbraucherschutz nicht. Also wenn ihr Probleme
habt, müsst ihr hoffen, dass AliExpress
beziehungsweise der Verkäufer euch
hilft. Und B müsst ihr auch bedenken,
dass das ganze Thema Rücknahmepflicht
und Recycling nicht gilt.
Also europäische Händler müssen ja alle
Geräte... Das stimmt. Juckt mich
persönlich allerdings nicht. Ich hatte
nie Probleme bei AliExpress
und also...
Unterm Strich nie Probleme.
Ich hatte natürlich schon Probleme mit dem
Versand von AliExpress, aber
AliExpress hat das immer zu
meiner Zufriedenheit gelöst.
Und sogar besser als der PayPal-Käuferschutz.
Deswegen kann ich
sagen, ich hatte unterm Strich nie
Probleme mit AliExpress.
Und gut, ich mein,
ich würd da drüber jetzt auch nix
massiv Teures bestellen, ja?
Also ich würd mir wahrscheinlich nichts
bestellen über AliExpress, was in der Summe
keine Ahnung, 8000 Euro,
20.000 Euro oder so kostet.
Das würd ich nicht machen.
Aber ich sag mal, meine Schmerzgrenze
bei AliExpress wäre
unter
1000 Euro, sollte es sein.
Also über 1000 Euro würd ich mir echt überlegen,
ob ich's bei AliExpress bestelle.
Falls denn doch mal was ist.
Aber die meisten Sachen, die ich bei AliExpress
bestelle, die halten sich ja auch
in Grenzen. Das war jetzt nix...
Ich weiß nicht, was das Teuerste war.
Kann ich euch aus dem Kopf nicht sagen.
Wahrscheinlich irgendwie 200, 300 Euro oder so.
Und
das wurde alles gut gehandhabt.
Das Recycling zurücknehmen,
das ist bei AliExpress nicht der Fall.
Also es gibt auf jeden Fall auch Mini-PC...
Wenn das Haus abfackelt, haftet der
Importeur. Wahrscheinlich wirst du haften dafür.
Alternativen mit N100-CPU,
die ihr ganz normal jetzt so lange bestellen könnt.
Allerdings ist die Kombination
aus 2,5 Zoll SATA-Slot
und 2,5 Gigabit
Netzwerkschnittstelle echt schwierig zu finden.
Ah ja, bevor ich tschüss sage,
CT hat einen echt ziemlich guten neuen...
TS-Fuchs sehe ich auch so.
Ja, da hätte ich auch meine
Bestuit, danke für den Sub.
Da hätte ich auch meine Bedenken.
Das ist halt so ein Batzen Geld.
Das ist nicht so ultra viel,
dass du jetzt irgendwie
Existenzprobleme danach bekommst,
wenn es weg ist. Aber es ärgert auf jeden Fall
schon richtig.
Ich würde das machen, bei AliExpress,
wenn es halt wirklich ein super
nices Angebot wäre. Exakt das,
was ich haben möchte.
Vielleicht auch in einer Ausführung, die es hier
bei uns nicht gibt. Ja, vielleicht flashbar
und das bei Amazon nicht flashbar, was auch immer.
Dann würde ich es trotzdem bestellen bei AliExpress.
Ich habe, wie gesagt, noch immer gute Erfahrungen gemacht.
Aber da hätte ich auch schon so ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen,
wenn denn was mit ist.
Weil eins muss man bei AliExpress mal auch
sagen, das was da steht
und das was man am Ende bekommt,
das muss im Detail nicht immer so
übereinstimmen.
Das ist genauso, wie wenn du dir bei AliExpress
mal guckst, wenn du dir Taschenlampen bestellen willst
bei AliExpress. Da steht dann irgendwie
da,
eine Million Lux
Helligkeit. Ich weiß nicht,
wie auch immer die das gemessen haben,
aber das ist ja komplett unrealistisch.
Die haben dann so, was weiß ich,
8000 Lux oder so.
Aber stehen halt da eine Million.
Also was da steht und was, es ist nicht
unbedingt immer so,
so ganz wortwörtlich
zu nehmen. Richtig.
Ja, AliExpress verkauft es nicht selbst.
Ja, so kann man es eigentlich
zusammenfassen. Ich hatte nie Probleme,
aber so wirklich, wirklich richtig gut
war es auch.
Nicht immer. Ja, das beste
Beispiel dafür ist zum Beispiel,
wenn du dir einen Microcontroller,
weil das ist was, was ich schon viel gemacht habe bei AliExpress,
Microcontroller und Elektronikkram bestellst.
Also, wenn du dir einen Microcontroller
bei AliExpress bestellst, kriegst du
oftmals einen gut
funktionierenden Microcontroller,
der dem entspricht, was du gekauft hast.
Was du allerdings nicht unbedingt
kriegst, ist ein Microcontroller,
der exakt im Detail
dem entspricht, was du denkst.
Zum Beispiel, wenn du dir bei AliExpress
wir nehmen jetzt mal
einen der beliebtesten
zumindest
lange Zeit, eines der beliebtesten
Controller, wenn du dir einen
Wemos D1 Mini kaufst,
da findest du
ganz viele bei AliExpress,
die zu
99% eben auch
identisch sind zu einem Wemos
D1 Mini. Problem ist nur,
das ist ein Nachbau.
Das ist nicht
zwangsläufig ein echter
Mini. Ein China
China-Chinesen-Nachbau
höchstwahrscheinlich.
Und der funktioniert auch
mit den Settings und so alles gut, aber im
Detail, also
du kriegst auf jeden Fall
gut was für dein Geld.
Im Detail kann sich das ein bisschen
unterscheiden. Ja, zum Beispiel
hier
auch relativ beliebt
ESP2866
die originale
NodeMCU
als Board
und wenn du dir da
ein AliExpress
was auch immer
AliExpress
wenn du dir da so einen Nachbau
kaufst, da kannst du Probleme bekommen,
wenn du dich auf
das originale
Datasheet vom Hersteller
verlässt.
Das originale Datasheet vom Hersteller
sagt, die haben
einen Spannungswandler
am
VIN-Input,
der verkraftet
5 bis 12 Volt.
Was enorm praktisch ist,
wenn du zum Beispiel diesen
Microcontroller anschließen möchtest oder verwenden
möchtest für LED-Steuerung.
Da hast du 12 Volt LED, du hast ein 12 Volt Netzteil,
da ist es sehr praktisch,
wenn das Ding 12 Volt Input verkraftet.
Problem ist nur,
dass die Nachbauten von AliExpress
viele der Nachbauten von
AliExpress
eben keinen Spannungswandler,
am VIN haben.
Und wenn du da dann 12 Volt anschließt,
oder auch nur ein bisschen mehr als 5,
dir das Board abfackelt.
Das ist halt so ein Ding,
das muss einem bei AliExpress
klar sein.
Du kriegst da gute Sachen und
manchmal aber halt auch
so ein paar Feinheiten, an die man
nicht gedacht hat.
Und das war ich aus erster Erfahrung, weil ich
habe schon welche gegrillt mit mehr als 5 Volt
NodeMCU Nachbauten.
Aber trotzdem, da ist es.
So, das würde ich auch mal kurz
durch, was empfiehlt
er denn hier?
TerraMaster F
What? Okay, komm.
Wir machen
das TerraMaster F4212
vor BayNAS.
Zwo Gig?
Öh. Das ist ja
nix. Das ist ja viel zu wenig.
Aber was ist da für ein, für ein...
Näääh.
Ich weiß nicht.
Also mir wäre das nicht gut.
Mir wäre eine x86 Kiste doch
erstaunlich,
äh, nicht erstaunlich,
mir wäre ja doch eine x86 Kiste
lieber.
Auf der anderen Seite,
wenn es eine Armkiste ist,
ist ja nicht, nicht pauschal
schlecht.
Ist die Frage, was da für ein OS draufkommt.
Was kommt da für ein OS drauf?
Öh. Oh, MediaVault.
Ah. Ah. Moment.
Moment. Moment.
Ah. Weiche.
Open Media Vault. Geh weg.
Warum nicht Unraid? Okay, warum nicht
Unraid?
Und zusätzlich noch Virtualisierung. Das müsste doch hier
die bessere Wahl sein.
Ja, das ist die Frage. Weiß nicht, wie gut
Unraid auf... Geht Unraid auf
ARM-CPUs überhaupt?
Gibt es das für ARM-CPUs?
Nun, ich habe mich hier bewusst
für die Virtualisierung mit Proxmox
Unraid ARM?
Nö.
Und dem NAS mit Open Media Vault.
Da ihr gerade, was die Hauptkomponente,
also Proxmox hier angeht,
wesentlich mehr Möglichkeiten...
Ja, das Problem ist, warum nicht Unraid?
Ist ganz einfach beantwortet, weil Unraid da drauf nicht läuft.
Was, der hatte ein
i3 im Video? Okay, dann würde ich
das tatsächlich nehmen, wenn es keine
ARM-CPU ist.
Ja, was ist das denn jetzt?
Da steht drin, dass es eine ARM-CPU ist.
Muss ich veräppeln? Das haben wir gerade vor zwei Minuten geguckt.
Vielleicht dann eher das?
Ja, keine Ahnung, also ich sehe
es da...
Was ist das denn?
Gibt es das denn mit
x86-CPU?
Tja, man...
Ne, da ist kein
i3 oder so drin.
Da hat irgendwas anderes...
Oh, keine Ahnung.
Hardware, okay.
Lass mal gucken, was drin ist.
Schauen wir uns mal an, welche Hardware ihr braucht. Logischerweise
ein TerraMaster NAS. Ihr könnt auch andere Modelle
nehmen, als das, das ich hier zeige.
Die Funktionalität ist bei vielen Modellen... Ach, guck mal!
Das ist ein F4424, der hat es falsch
verlinkt unten. Ne.
Hä?
Ach,
Amazon ist einfach wieder ultra
pepega wahrscheinlich hier, hm?
Hä? Alter, Amazon!
Oh, Mann.
F4424.
Das TerraMaster.
Hatten die mal nicht so eine Shopping
Seite hier, irgendwie?
Es ist ja mal wieder super
weird, wo kann man das kaufen überhaupt?
Wow, okay!
Jetzt kommen wir aber in preisliche Regionen, da kann man
sich jetzt drüber streiten, wie sinnig das da ist.
Okay, geil zahlt's.
Chat gedenkt wieder mit.
Excellent.
Okay, das hat man eben nicht gefunden.
Ja, nice. Das ist im Prinzip
das...
Ja, da muss man preislich schon gucken.
Das klingt nach einer sinnvollen...
Das klingt tatsächlich nach einer sinnvollen Hardware.
So kommen wir auf 5 Ports,
4 Base und
CPU.
Was ist drinne?
N95 Quadcore.
Wat?
Was soll das
sein? Alter!
Alder Lake.
Also auch so ein Low Power Ding.
Guck, was hat
er denn hier drinne?
Ich hab euch natürlich dieses Modell, das ich hier
verwende, auch mit den zwei CPU-Ausführungen.
Unten in der Videobeschreibung verlinkt.
Dann braucht ihr natürlich noch logischerweise
Ja, was ist denn jetzt drinne?
...
Okay, weiß man nicht.
Ja, okay. Ja, aber das muss ich
sagen, das sieht tatsächlich auch nicht nach einem
schlechten Case
aus, weil
ich mag für
Netzwerk-Storage
solche Wechselrahmen-
Systeme.
Weil es einfach praktisch ist und man kommt
schön dran. Ich habe so einen HP
Microserver, der hat nochmal eine ganze Ecke mehr
CPU-Power als so ein Ding.
Die brauche ich aber eigentlich gar nicht so wirklich.
Und da
ist es ein bisschen umständlicher,
die Platten rein und raus zu kriegen.
Haben zwar auch so einen Rahmen dafür, wo man
die schön rein und raus, aber ist nicht so
schön, wie wenn du einfach vorne das Ganze wechseln
kannst.
Was mich jetzt noch interessieren würde, hat das
Gehäuse irgendwie die Möglichkeiten
LED-Anzeigen
an den Wechsel
vorne zu machen.
Wofür sind
die LEDs? Sind die einfach nur
für den
Betrieb oder
können die angesteuert werden
für Fehler?
Weil ansonsten musst du dir auf jeden
Fall hier vorne mit irgend so einem Etikett
oder so draufschreiben, die Seriennummer
von den Platten, die drin sind, dass du später erkennst,
welche Platte du austauschen musst,
wenn was kaputt geht.
Ja, der Vorteil gegenüber dem Desktop,
einem richtig alten Desktop, ist
auf jeden Fall der Stromverbrauch.
Und was bei diesen
Nassgehäusen halt auch praktisch ist, du kommst
halt einfach an die Platten dran, was bei
normalen PC-Gehäusen nicht der
Fall ist.
Trotzdem, die sind seit Jahren
schon so
leistungsstark, normale
PCs, dass du damit easy
2,5 Gig
Saturated kriegst
und du hast auch genug PC-Express-Steckplätze,
um Netzwerkkarten und alles
reinzupappen. Also, alter PC hat auch seine
Vorteile.
Größter Nachteil ist tatsächlich
der Stromverbrauch.
Und dass es nicht so schön ist, an die Platten dranzukommen.
Was haben wir denn sonst noch hier?
Stupsi, die älteste Katze der...
Ja, genau. Cat-Content.
Das muss jetzt sein.
Excellent.
Stupsi hat das ganz große losgezogen.
Ihren Lebensabend verbringt die
betagte Katze in ihrem eigenen
Zimmer in Altötting.
Das muss jetzt so sein, denn die vermutlich
älteste Miete der Welt...
Wisst ihr, das ist eine Sache, die mag ich an
alten Katzen. Die sind so super entspannt.
Die hängen immer rum
und
äh...
sind einfach sehr
gechillt, ja.
...hat inzwischen doch einige Wehwehchen.
Sie ist halt blind und taub.
Blind und taub, kriegt
nix halt.
Wie gesagt, ich hatte ja auch schon einige
Katzen, die ein bisschen älter waren.
Unter anderem
hier, Chico. Hier unten.
Die da. Chico ist...
Ich weiß es gar nicht, wie alt die geworden ist. Am Ende jetzt 14
oder 15 oder so? 14?
Irgendwie... Irgendwie 13?
14? 15? Ich weiß es gar nicht genau.
Das ist jetzt noch
nicht super alt
für Katzen, aber auch schon älter.
Und die hat halt auch Probleme.
Und die anderen auch. Ist halt ab einem gewissen
Alter.
Aber so im Großen und Ganzen
geht es ihr eigentlich ganz gut.
Umgerechnet etwa 130
Menschenjahre hat Stupsi auf dem
Katzenbuckel. Auch deshalb
wird sie nach Strich und Faden verwöhnt.
Ja, was eine Fein.
Als
Marina Takovic vor einiger Zeit
mit ihrer Mutter alte Fotos
ansieht, stellen beide überrascht
fest, dass die Katze vor
vielen Jahren... Die war schon immer da!
...bereits auf dem Bauernhof lebte.
Sie beginnen nachzurechnen.
Ja, Dscheko gibt es
seit Dezember nicht mehr.
Das Foto mit Stupsi ist auf den Februar 1995
datiert. Das heißt,
sie muss im... Warum
krabbeln da irgendwelche Spinnen unter den Fotos rum?
Das finde ich... Ach ne, das ist
irgendeine Mücke, die gelandet ist. Das fand ich jetzt
irritierend irgendwie.
Das heißt, sie muss im Herbst
1994 auf die Welt
gekommen sein. Da war ihr Mama früher da?
Antike Katze.
Die Stupsi war
im alten Ägypten schon am Start.
Dann ist sie
so eine
brave, starke Hofkatze geworden.
Immer unauffällig, aber immer da.
Vor Weihnachten dann der Schock.
Die alte Stupsi war plötzlich
verschwunden. Es wird das
Schlimmste befürchtet. Doch die
Katzen-Seniorin sitzt verwirrt
auf der Straße und landet im
Tierheim. Marina entdeckt sie
auf Facebook und holt sie
für sich. Im Haus gibt es
genügend andere tierische
Verstärkung. Aber Stupsi liegt
ihren Besitzern besonders am
Herzen. Weil sie war früher schon immer überall
dabei. Sie hat uns im Garten
begleitet. Sie ist einmal mit spazieren gegangen.
Und sie war sehr agil,
als die Maise angegangen ist. Sie hat
fleißig gefangen und auch fleißig hergezockt.
Und hat sich mit dem Matz gefreut.
Ja, geht halt jetzt
leider nicht mehr so. Einen
amtlichen Beweis dafür, dass Stupsi die
älteste Katze der Welt ist, gibt
es nicht. Aber der Rekord
ist ihrer Familie gar nicht
so wichtig. Sie darf da in dem
Zimmer mit Heizung wohnen.
Ja, Heizung ist das Beste.
Kleine Aufmerksamkeit, wie
so ein Schmusekissen, das mit
Baldrian getränkt ist.
Das macht es dann schon ein bisschen
schöner. Bei Baldrian
flippt es aus. Wenn es dann noch ein bisschen
Freude hat. Ein bisschen
Sonnenlicht auf alte Knochen
kann dabei nicht schaden.
Was haben wir denn hier jetzt?
Lohnsicht, Schädlings...
Oh ne, das wird eklig, Leute.
Ich weiß nicht... Ne, das kann ich mir
jetzt nicht angucken. Wobei Kakerlaken
schocken mich nicht so sehr.
Was verdient man als Schädling? Wahrscheinlich
nicht genug.
Nicht genug, dass ich das
machen würde.
Also man darf
auf jeden Fall keinen Ekel haben vor Schädlingen.
Das ist natürlich der Hauptpunkt.
Ja.
Im Freundeskreis kam da schon
ein paar Witze.
Du Rattenfänger.
Ich habe da echt meinen Weg gefunden.
Ich kann mir das auch vorstellen, bis zum Rentenalter zu machen.
Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast.
Hallo, ich bin Adrian, bin 27 Jahre alt.
Ich bin Schädlingsbekämpfer und komme aus Baden-Württemberg.
Ich bin immer monatlich da.
Und das Monitoring
machen wir heute.
Muss kontrolliert werden.
Erstmal Nagios installieren.
Keine Schädlinge auftreten.
Da sind mehrere Fallen und da habe ich Giftköder dabei.
Oder auch andere Köder.
Und dann gucken wir nach, ob da jetzt ein Befall
feststeht oder nicht.
Okay, wir würden jetzt einmal reingehen zu den Kunden.
Oh, alles klar.
Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast, Toast.
Servus. Hallo.
Alles gut?
Keine besondere Auffälligkeit.
Okay, perfekt. Das hört man immer gerne.
Okay, wir würden
jetzt einmal runtergehen.
Wir im Keller haben hier Fallen installiert.
Hier ist die erste Falle.
Der erste Monitor, sagen wir dazu.
Das sieht ein bisschen wie bei mir im Keller aus.
Als Fachbegriff.
Und das ist eine Mottenfalle.
Lebensmittelbetriebe kommen das öfter mal vor.
Mehlmotten vor allem.
Klar, wenn Mehl in der Nähe ist, da könnten jetzt Motten auftreten.
Aber hier ist jetzt zum Beispiel gar nichts.
Es ist so, bei jedem Monitor
haben wir hier unseren Scanner.
Und da haben wir so ein eigenes
Programm.
Und dann schreiben wir jetzt
rein, kein Befall festgestellt.
Wäre da jetzt ein Befall, dann schreiben wir natürlich Befall
so und so viele Motten.
Also vier oder fünf Motten.
Und welche Motten.
Ich habe meistens Monitoring-Kunden.
Das ist ja monatlich.
Da ist meistens schon ein Fixtermin.
Also, keine Ahnung, am 15. April muss ich da hin.
Am 10. Mai muss ich da hin.
Das ist eigentlich unser Hauptgeschäft.
Beobachten, kontrollieren, ob was auftreten könnte.
Das heißt jetzt nicht, dass wir zum Kunden gehen
und es ist akut was.
Kann natürlich auch sein. Und dann leiten wir eine Bekämpfung ein.
Also hier ist ein Schabenmonitor.
Da ist jetzt zum Beispiel ein Jungtier von einer deutschen Schabe drauf.
Genau.
Also wird...
Ah!
Also quasi eine Baby-Kakerlake sozusagen.
Wahrscheinlich hier die Mutter noch rumlaufen.
Und jetzt schaue ich noch mal
in der Ecke, ob da noch andere Merkmale sein
könnten, ob hier Schaben sind.
Hier zum Beispiel in der Ecke sind auf jeden Fall noch
tote Schaben. Das Problem ist,
das kann ich leider nicht verschieben hier.
Aber mit dem
können wir da leider nicht ran.
Die müssen auf jeden Fall weg, weil
auch wenn eine Kontrolle hier ist vom Gesundheitsamt
oder anderen, kommt das nicht so gut.
Aber später gehe ich mit dem Chef noch mal hierher
und schaue auf jeden Fall nach.
Hier zum Beispiel ist auch der perfekte
Hotspot,
dass Schaben sich auffallen können, weil hier ist warm und feucht.
Hier fühlen die sich auf jeden Fall pudelwohl.
Da hat sich mein Verdacht auf jeden Fall bestätigt.
Ich handle jetzt auf jeden Fall.
Ich gehe jetzt noch mal zum Auto und hole mein Schabengel
und meine Fallen und dann werden wir das
auf jeden Fall bekämpfen können.
Das ist so ein bestimmter Wirkstoff, der wirkt halt
gegen Schaben, dass sie sterben. Die fressen das
und dann bringen die das halt ins Nest
und dann sterben alle, weil die Kannibalen sind.
Okay, dann würden wir wieder reingehen.
Sprich, die fressen alles.
Sie fressen sich untereinander auch.
Da habe ich hier meine Schabengelpistole
im Einzelstil.
Also der englische Fachbegriff ist Baitgun.
Aber wir sagen ungarnsprachig Schabenpistole.
Natürlich meine Handschuhe anziehen.
Dadurch, dass wir hier Schaben
in dem Monitor gesehen wurden,
werde ich jetzt überall hier
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine Heißkleber.
Heißkleber.
Schabengelpunkte setzen.
An jedem Hotspot.
Genau, so kleine Punkte.
Für die Schaben
ist das jetzt ungefähr so wie
Nix wie weg.
Kennt man fast gar nicht.
Die mache ich jetzt überall hier rein,
wo sich Schaben gerne aufhalten.
Also hier habe ich letztes Mal schon so eine Papierpfeile
für Schaben aufgestellt.
Und siehe da,
ist einiges los.
Dann setze ich mal hier wieder ein paar Gelpunkte.
In alten Häusern ist öfter mal
kann ein Schabenbefall entstehen,
weil halt alles so alt gebaut ist.
Also ich denke eher, das liegt an den Baulichtmängeln.
An der Hygiene liegt es hier zum Beispiel gar nicht.
Wenn man die Ausbrunnen abschließt, kann man eigentlich
alles töten, außer was natürlich unter Artenschutz steht.
Das ist verboten, aber sonst ist man erlaubt,
jedes Schädling zu bekämpfen.
Das machen wir nur, wenn die Kamera nicht dabei ist.
Das ist jetzt die letzte Falle.
Genau, eine Rattenbox auf dem Balkon.
Wenn jetzt der Köder angefressen wäre,
dann ist auf jeden Fall Rattenbefall.
Hier ist jetzt nicht so der Fall.
Perfekt, also
gehe ich nicht davon aus, dass hier Ratten sind.
Da schreibe ich dann einfach in mein System rein
keinen Befall.
Mein konkreter Auftrag ist, den Kunden hier
zu beraten, ob irgendwelche Mängel sind
oder hygienische Mängel, bauliche Mängel,
was sie vielleicht verbessern könnten,
dass keine Schädlinge mehr hier auftreten.
Und natürlich, dadurch, dass sie auch hier überall
unsere Fallen und Systeme aufgestellt haben,
da schaue ich dann, ob da was sein könnte
oder nicht.
Also ich bin zum Monitoring hier.
Aber natürlich, wenn sowas anfällt, dass auf den Fallen was ist,
dann muss man halt handeln.
Und das haben wir auch so abgemacht, dass ich dann immer handel.
Okay, dann würden wir kurz runter gehen.
Schabencheck.
Dann müssen wir vorziehen wieder.
Das wäre gut, wenn wir die vielleicht vorziehen könnten.
Sind die Papierpresse dann heute Nachmittag vor?
Ja. Okay, machen wir.
Und da brauchen wir auch ein paar Leute mit Muckis,
weil die ist ziemlich schwer und dann
ziehen wir sie vor und gucken, da gehen wir.
Dann bräuchte ich gerade wie immer hier
die Unterschrift im weißen Feld.
Perfekt.
Diese Dinger, da musst du ja auch teilweise
unterschreiben, wenn die Post vorbeikommt.
Da drauf sieht meine Unterschrift null aus,
wie meine Unterschrift auf diesen Dingern.
Alles klar. Dankeschön.
Ciao.
Manchmal fehlen ganze Striche und so.
Kann auch mal sein, dass man länger im Auto ist.
Einmal eine gute 2-3 Stunden hin
und 2-3 Stunden zurück.
Ist immer unterschiedlich. Aber heute ist es zum Beispiel so,
dass wir echt alles in derselben Stadt haben.
Das passt halt gut.
Ich habe in Mannheim erstmal
die mittlere Reife abgeschlossen.
Dann habe ich erstmal eine Ausbildung angefangen
zur Fachkraft für Lagerlogistik.
Habe die aber nach 2 Jahren abgebrochen.
Und danach habe ich mal eine Ausbildung
zum Hotelfachmann ausprobiert.
Das habe ich auch abgebrochen.
Und dann habe ich auch eine Ausbildungsmesse,
den Beruf, wo ich jetzt ausübe, kennengelernt.
Schädlingsbekämpfer.
Und habe dort 3 Jahre die Ausbildung gemacht.
Guck mal, der hat einfach 3 Aus...
Ach ne, hier abgebrochen, abgebrochen.
Wo hat der einfach 3x3 Ausbildung gemacht?
Ausübe, kennengelernt,
Schädlingsbekämpfer.
Und habe dort 3 Jahre die Ausbildung gemacht.
Weil wenn man 3 Ausbildungen
verkackt hat, dann will sich keiner mehr.
Deswegen war der Druck dann schon höher.
Aber keine Ahnung.
Ich habe mich viel mehr wertgeschätzt gefühlt.
Die Leute waren viel glücklicher.
Man braucht halt einfach manchmal eine Weile,
bis man das gefunden hat, was einem Bock macht.
Anscheinend ist es bei ihm Schädlingsbekämpfer.
Wir sehen das in Deutschland,
finde ich, an vielen Stellen
einfach viel zu kritisch.
Vielmehr mal gelobt.
Die haben einen vielmehr...
Die Personalabteilung
wieder irgendwelche Sachen reinfantasieren.
...Lagerlogistik oder Hotelfranche.
Wir haben einen zweiten Kunden heute.
Da wird auch wieder Monitoring durchgeführt.
Da sind wir monatlich.
Interessant wird halt,
letzten Monat war ich da und da war in der
Reinigungsmaschine, da waren
Schaben, also Kakerlaken.
Muss ich mal schauen, ob die immer noch dort sind.
Hier war ein sehr starker Befall.
Im Februar.
Frage ist auch, ob das wieder deutsche
Kakerlaken sind.
Wundert mich das oder ich bin auch glücklich,
weil da waren die ganzen Fallen richtig voll.
Und da sind dann auch wirklich
Schaben auch rausgesprungen.
Also die hat man direkt gesehen. Akut.
Aber es scheint sich erledigt zu haben.
Also es sieht gut aus.
Wir haben ja keinen sozialen Beruf,
aber irgendwie ist es ja auch ein bisschen sozial,
weil wir helfen den Leuten.
Die Leute, die diese Produkte bekommen, sind glücklich.
Das kannst du dann zu jeder Dienstleistung
sagen.
Wo Leute zu dir kommen und was haben wollen.
Ich bin ja auch schon ein bisschen sozial.
Ich habe seinen Internetanschluss
repariert. Vorne ist da auch
sehr sozial.
Also das macht mich echt glücklich.
Mittagspause.
Früher bin ich öfter mal
zum Bäcker gegangen.
Ich habe auch übelst Hunger. Ich muss gleich was füttern.
Oder Döner.
Aber ich habe einfach gemerkt, es geht sehr ins Geld.
Das stimmt wohl.
Deswegen mache ich mir lieber was selber. Ist auch gesünder.
Das sieht aus wie
sieht ein bisschen aus
wie das, was ich abends mittlerweile auch fütter.
Seit einer Weile.
Bananen oder
irgendwelche Obstzinger mit Haferflocken dabei.
Ein bisschen Quark.
Das macht gut satt und verträgt man gut
abends.
Okay, Mittagspause
ist jetzt zu Ende. Wir haben 13 Uhr.
Ich fahre zum nächsten Kunden, zum nächsten Bäcker.
Mal gucken, was mich da erwartet.
Letzte Stunde das Ding gefuttert.
Da wurde mal eine Maus gesichtet
vor längerer Zeit und da wollen wir so Elektrofall
installieren. Und wir kriegen dann eine Benachrichtigung.
auf unser Programm.
Smart Traps
IOT Mausefall
Hier ist ein Müllraum.
Und da ist hier eine Maus umgesprungen.
Da war ganz hinten noch älterer Mäusekot.
Der ist schon getrocknet aber.
Und jetzt würde ich halt hier
die neuen Funkfallen ausprobieren.
Es gibt schon immer die klassischen
Tunnelfallen mit zwei Schlagfallen
integriert.
Aber jetzt ist es so, die funktionieren mit Funk.
Ich mach mal hier direkt mal
eine.
Und hier könnte ich echt eine aufhalten.
Dann installiert man so Antennen
für den Funk, dass man
einen guten Empfang hat.
Und da kommt dann wahrscheinlich irgendeine SIM-Karte oder so rein.
Das macht dann alles noch einfacher. Man muss nicht mehr jeden Tag hierher kommen
und kontrollieren und der Kunde auch nicht selbst.
Man kann dann einfach die Benachrichtigung
bekommen und man sieht dann, wenn was drin ist,
die geht vorbei.
Also ich verdiene 3.000 Euro brutto monatlich.
Bekomme 2.050 Euro netto raus.
Und dann bekomme ich noch 500 Euro
ohne Abschläge Urlaubsgeld im Jahr.
Und nach Hause komme ich dann meistens wie jetzt
zwischen 16 und 17 Uhr.
Meistens höre ich meinen Kunden so um 16 Uhr auf
und dann ist halt das Problem mit dem Verkehr.
Kann sein, dass ich dann gut durchkomme
und bin um 17 Uhr zuhause, aber kann auch sein, dass
es halt ein Unfall war oder der Feierabendverkehr so schlimm,
dass ich dann erst um 18 Uhr
18.30 Uhr mal zuhause bin.
Oh, das suckt.
Leider kann man das halt schlecht
Homeoffice-technisch ausüben.
Wenn zwar alles elektronisch ist
und man nur noch auf die Fallen gucken muss,
vielleicht ab und zu.
Wichtig ist immer natürlich
die Schuhe auszuziehen, gerade wenn so ein
Schabenauftrag wie heute war mit Kakerlaken.
Weil nicht, dass man die in die Wohnung
reinschleppt. Dann ziehe ich die Schuhe immer
vor der Tür aus.
Wie war dein Tag?
Ja, war gut. Viele Kakerlaken
heute wieder.
Also hier wohne ich auf 61 Quadratmeter
und ich bezahle 600 Euro monatlich Warmmiete.
Ich kann mich, also
ich hatte nie irgendwo Kakerlaken.
Das Einzige, wo ich mich dran erinnern kann,
weil ich es super eklig fand, wo ich klein war,
da waren wir mal im Urlaub irgendwo in Spanien
oder so und in der Wohnung,
die wir dort hatten, in diesem Bungalow,
gab es Kakerlaken.
Das war eklig.
Da haben wir dann auch, glaub ich, irgendwann neun.
Ich kann mich noch ganz dunkel dran erinnern.
Ich geh mir am Morgen,
ich geh mir essen.
Ich hab auch sehr Hunger, ich freu mich schon.
Das sieht nicht aus wie die Tür, die nach draußen geht.
Das sieht, weil das so dunkel ist,
das sieht aus, als gehen die jetzt gerade in irgendeine Abstellkammer, oder?
Ich geh mir am Morgen.
So, okay, lass mal kurz in die Abstellkammer rein.
Ich mach die Tür zu.
Ich hab auch sehr Hunger, ich freu mich schon.
Ich hab mein Auto 2020 gekauft
und das hat 12.000 Euro gekostet,
aber ich zahl das monatlich mit 250 Euro ab.
Bis 2025.
Also wir mögen es immer zu reisen
und woanders hinzugehen.
Wir wohnen halt in der Pampa
und haben was Schönes zu erleben oder Cooles.
Also wir sparen gerade
für die Peru-Reise im August.
Wir fliegen nämlich im August nach Peru, in ihr Heimatland.
Wie man unschwer erkennen kann.
Und da gehen wir auch noch nach Bolivia,
auf eine Hochzeit von Freunden von Stuttgart.
Und das Ganze kostet halt 5.000 Euro
für beide insgesamt.
Und da müssen wir halt viel sparen.
Ich hab da echt meinen Weg gefunden.
Ich kann mir das auch vorstellen,
noch bis zum Rentenalter zu machen.
Der Anzeigenhauptmeister, den haben wir uns schon mal angeguckt.
Gibt es da eigentlich einen zweiten Teil?
Mittlerweile von?
Also wirklich reich wirst du als Schädlingsbekämpfer
ja nicht.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall zu wenig
für das, dass ich sowas ekliges machen würde.
Er ist heute bei Monte im Stream.
Der Anzeigenhauptmeister persönlich.
250 Euro Überschuss ist schon knapp.
Wobei man sagen muss, Lifestyle ist schon vorher weg.
Essen und so ist schon alles weg.
Also auf so eklige Sachen hätt ich eh keinen Bock.
Da müssten die mir deutlich mehr bezahlen.
Aber gut,
dass es Leute gibt, die das machen.
So, das war's von mir.
Ich hoffe, ihr hattet Spaß.
Wenn ihr wollt, schaut euch nochmal hier den Müllmann an.
Und hier den Anlagenmechaniker.
Ciao, macht's gut.
See you.
Ja gut, dass es Leute gibt,
die das machen.
Das wäre echt nichts für mich.
Ich mein, von Kakerlaken und so, das ekelt mich jetzt nicht so.
Aber Bock hätte ich da nicht drauf.
Mäuse habe ich auch keine Probleme.
Wo du dich als Schädlingsbekämpfer
auch mit auseinandersetzen musst.
OpenWRT auf KVM, but why?
AlexiBexi, das ist so ein Channel,
den kann ich mir einfach nicht angucken.
Obwohl man ja eigentlich vermuten würde,
dass der vom Content her ein bisschen was macht,
was mich durchaus interessieren könnte.
Aber ich kann mir das nicht angucken.
Das ist immer so anstrengend zu schauen.
Downsizing.
Ja endlich mal einer, der was Sinnvolles macht.
This is my homelab.
Endlich mal einer, der was Sinnvolles macht.
Oversized Shit
einfach ein bisschen abbauen.
Ja, das ist die Frage,
die ich bei so gut wie jedem Homelab-Video stelle.
Was machen die eigentlich damit?
Bei TechnoTim habe ich es bis heute nicht verstanden,
was er darauf macht.
Außer Management für das Management für das Management
und dann im Endeffekt ein Dashboard.
Wir machen kein OpenWRT heute.
Gucken uns OpenObserve an
als Monitoring für daheim.
Mal gucken, ob das was taugt.
Das Downsizing macht durchaus Sinn.
Ich meine, außer
man hat dann wirklich handfeste Gründe,
Argumente dafür, dass man sagt, ey,
ich brauche hier oben
mindestens mal
5 Server und
irgendwie 3
NUCs oder was das ist.
Wo sonst?
Die meisten werden es nicht brauchen.
Ich gebe ja zu, ich kenne das auch,
dass das so einen gewissen
haben wollen Faktor hat,
ja.
Ich meine, ich bin ja schon nicht normal
aus Sicht der meisten Leute mit meinem
Serverraum.
Aber da ist viel, viel
weniger drin, als das, was man in diesen Videos immer sieht.
Da steht ein HP
Microserver drin, den habe ich jetzt auch schon eine Weile.
Ein 10Gig-Switch,
3D-Drucker,
mein ganzes oder meiste
vom Werkzeug,
Router
und die FRITZ!Box. Das war's.
Gibt es ein paar Videos bei mir auf YouTube. Ich müsste mal wieder,
das muss ich mir mal aufräumen.
Serverraum-Update-Video.
Hast du den ZigBee-Stick schon geflasht?
Ja, habe ich gemacht.
Sogar im Stream.
Aber wenn du so fragst, vermute ich mal,
du warst nicht dabei.
Das war easy,
war das, hier.
Also, der ZigBee-Stick, das war wirklich
easy as fuck.
Ja, da, guck.
Von der gesamten
Sache habe ich 30 Minuten den Stick geflasht.
Den Rest habe ich irgendwie, weil ich das andere
nicht geguckt habe. Ich habe was gegessen dabei.
Eine Smart-Home-Tour, ja.
Wollte ich.
Link, please.
Geh ins Archiv.
Archiv.
What's. Klick das an.
Es gibt sogar einen Link zum Archiv.
Moment, geht das noch?
Ist das noch richtig?
Es redirected.
Ah!
What redirected?
Ach, guck mal!
Wir haben sogar einen Link
zum YouTube-Channel.
Super Projekt.
Moment, es gibt tatsächlich
mal Kommentare in diesem What-Channel.
Ist das so?
Wait a minute. Wer? Alter!
Mordkiss, ihr seid ja sowas von high IQ.
Sind das
auto-generated
Captions? Nee, nicht Captions.
Auto-generated Chapters?
Oder werden die wirklich von Hand generated
von euch, ey?
Ja, nice, dass man sich da so viel Mühe macht.
Das Archiv ist eh
die biggest high IQ-Sache
überhaupt.
Was machen die per Hand? Meine Güte, ey.
Richtige,
schlaue, massive, big brain
Mods. Aber ich glaube nicht,
dass das automatisch erkennt,
es geht weiter mit Programmieren. Das glaube ich nicht.
Wie dem auch sei, Leute,
heute Mittag, höchstwahrscheinlich,
gucken wir uns Open Observe an, weil es mich persönlich
interessiert. Vielleicht werden wir nochmal ein bisschen streamen.
Ich geh jetzt auf. Ich geh jetzt was futtern.
Ach ja, dreimal dürft ihr raten,
was es heute gibt. Es ist nicht Lachs.
Es ist nicht Nudel mit Lachs, es ist
Spaghetti Bolognese.
Die übliche, übliche
Sonntagmittag-
Sache.
Wir sehen uns später. Macht's gut, bis denn.
See you.